Pierre Guillaume Mercadal, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Pierob
Mercadal, éleveur de cochon dans le
sud-ouest de la France en bio, en hyper
extensif et et plutôt engagé pour la
cause paysane.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler nourriture, on
va parler souveraineté alimentaire, on
va parler est-ce que le prix de la
bouffe va augmenter dans nos assiettes,
est-ce que nos agriculteurs vont
continuer à se suicider
tous les jours ? Tous les jours tous les
jours à se faire étrangler tous les
jours tous les jours ? parce que l'État
français va continuer à à ne pas
soutenir, ne pas défendre notre
agriculture millénaire, nos traditions
culinaire et notre patrimoine.
Première question que je vais vous
poser, c'est pas une question, c'est
montrez-moi vos mains pour savoir si
vous êtes pas un agriculteur de bureau.
Fais fais un zoom sur les mains de
monsieur.
Voilà, c'est bien, tu peux redézoomer.
Je pose cette question parce que en ce
moment, il y a beaucoup d'agriculteurs
de bureau qui s'expriment au nom des
agriculteurs et et connaissant un peu
les agriculteurs euh on sait reconnaître
que des mains sales, ça veut dire de
l'argent propre.
Donc aujourd'hui, première question,
votre exploitation, elle fait quelle
taille ? Vous avez combien de cochons ?
Vous faites quel chiffre d'affair ? Vous
faites ça depuis combien de temps ?
Pourquoi vous avez fait ça ? Et ensuite
on passe au sujet plus généralisé.
Pas de souci. Alors ben mon exploitation
elle fait 40 hactares, donc 40 hactares
uniquement de forêt. Euh j'ai environ
j'ai une bonne centaine de cochons. Le
but ça va être d'arriver à peu près à
150 parce qu'en fait j'élève très
lentement. J'élève sur 2 ans. Ce qui à
titre comparatif en en bâtiment c'est
moins de 6 mois. Moi c'est 2 ans, donc
c'est très long. Donc, il faut un
roulement pour que j'en transforme à peu
près un par semaine. Et l'objectif,
c'est de faire à peu près à peu près
100000 € de chiffre d'affaires par an
pour un revenu de 100 à 2000 € par mois
à peu près. Voilà, c'est ça l'objectif.
Pourquoi vous avez fait ça ?
C'est l'agricole, c'est une vocation.
C'est c'est un choix.
Exactement. Un sacerdoce. Oui, mais
c'est sûr qu'il y a des côtés très durs,
mais
c'est une joie et en fait que tous les
amis que je peux avoir qui sont citadins
comprennent quand ils viennent à la
maison. de se lever dans ce cadre le
matin, d'être dans la nature, même si on
fait un nombre d'heures, les 35 heures,
on les on les a terminé mercredi, mais
c'est une joie indescriptible et puis
c'est une connexion à la nature, aux
animaux, le fait de de travailler avec
le vivant, donc de jamais avoir les
mêmes paysages, les mêmes problèmes, les
mêmes c'est hyper enrichissant, c'est
fabuleux. Puis c'est quelque chose qu'en
fait on a tous en nous parce qu'on vient
tous de paysan en fait. Et quand on met
un coup de fourchette, un coup de
couteau, on sait si ça a bien été fait
ou pas.
Exactement.
C'est des valeurs qui se perdent ça.
Oui.
Euh question. On vous présente souvent
dans la presse, ce qui ne veut plus rien
dire maintenant à notre époque, comme un
agriculteur d'extrême droite, un
agriculteur réac, un agriculteur
d'extrême gauche, un agriculteur
d'extrême d'extrême d'extrême d'extrême.
On a Pourquoi on vous présente comme ça
? On a vu que certaines vidéos vous
déposiez des choses devant certaines
choses qu'on ne cautionne pas mais on
les comprend.
Euh pourquoi on vous présente comme ça ?
Bah on me présente comme ça parce que
bah j'ai toujours milité en fait pour la
cause paysane. C'est c'est comme le
métier de paysan. C'est un truc ça te
prend au trip et puis quand tu vois
toute la misère qu'il y a dans le monde
agricole. Voilà.
Vous êtes élu syndicaliste. C'est ça.
Oui, tout à fait. Ça peut pas laisser
insensible. Et je précise d'ailleurs que
ça fait presque 20 ans que je suis
là-dedans, mais que j'ai jamais eu un
centime même de comment dirais-je de
d'ffrément
de défraimment. Voilà, merci pour le
mot. Et
excuse-moi, je viens de perdre le fil.
Euh
on est entre cutéreux donc on peut se
tutoyer.
Oui. Oui. Excuse Oui. Donc oui. Non mais
je veux dire pour la question. Est-ce
que tu peux me reposer la question ?
Excuse-moi, j'ai perdu le fil.
Pourquoi on vous présente ?
Oui, voilà.
Euh ben donc du coup j'ai été de prés
j'ai oui il faut que ça aille dans les
deux sens. Ben en fait, j'ai été
beaucoup soutenu par l'extrême gauche à
mes débuts parce que je suis en bio
installé horcade familial. mes
grands-parents étaient paysans, mais pas
mes parents, on les a poussé à aller à
la fonction publique. Euh
et donc du coup, j'étais plutôt soutenu
par l'extrême gauche mais un peu
mollement et tu vois, enfin je les
critique pas parce qu'on est à 1 heure
où les le monde agricole doit s'unir
s'il veut survivre et même au-delà du
monde agricole les Français en général
mais un peu mollement tu vois, un peu
sans voilà sans aller au carton et ma
situation empirée empirée empirée parce
que bah j'ai été au prise avec de
milliardaires. Aujourd'hui, je ne suis
plus au prise qu'avec un seul mais qui
est l'un des plus puissants de France.
Donc c'est c'est pas de tout repos. Et
et en fait, j'ai été sauvé par un ami à
moi qui s'appelle Papacito qui est un
youtubeur très connu, royaliste à droite
plutôt. Et du coup bah vu que je suis
l'ami de Papacito, je suis forcément un
nazi, n'est-ce pas ? Et lui aussi alors
qu'il est oni par l'ultra extrême
droite, mais c'est pas grave, peu
importe. Euh donc voilà. Donc un coup,
je suis d'extrême gauche, un coup je
suis d'extrême droite. Mais au final des
propos euh d'extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche, on peut les chercher, il y en a
pas me concernant. Euh après, oui, par
contre le truc c'est que je vais au bout
des choses. Et alors du coup, ben par
exemple, le fait de de déposer un cochon
mort sur le bureau d'un mère parce qu'on
a des animaux empoisonnés, assassinés à
coup de physique, après j'ai eu des
histoires avec des maladies qui
n'existent que dans mon que dans mon
élevage et cetera. Euh bon ben moi
disons que je ne me laisse pas faire et
ça ça plaît pas surtout quand on se
laisse pas faire devant la la sacrosinte
franc-maçonnerie et la presse aux ordres
parce que journaliste est un métier bien
noble mais comme tu as pu le dire
aujourd'hui
c'est un peu triste le bilan
onisoi qui mal y pense
en tant que jeune agriculteur encore
vivant soutenu par une partie de la
France qui
souhaite se réenraciner ou retrouver ses
racines. Comment tu sens la France en
terme de souveraineté alimentaire, en
terme de capacité des agriculteurs à
nourrir son peuple, ses peuples ? Toi,
comment tu vois les deux prochaines, les
trois prochaines années, comment et
pourquoi ? Quelles sont les menaces et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour éviter
que nos agriculteurs calanchent
parce que ça devient compliqué, trop
compliqué.
Alors ben la menace principale c'est
l'Union européenne parce que ce qui tue
le monde agricole vraiment ce qui le
crève quelle que soit la production
c'est la concurrence des loyales qu'on
subi avec le fait qu'il y ait aucun
contrôle aux frontières et que du coup
les agriculteurs soient soumis à des
normes en France mais qu'on importe par
million de tonnes de la CAM qui n'est
pas soumise aux mêmes normes.
Ensuite, tu as un problème générationnel
parce que aujourd'hui la moyenne d'âge
est à plus de 50 ans. Donc on sait que
d'ici 5 ans, on aura la moitié des
paysans français qui seront à la
retraite. Euh
et en fait, il y a beaucoup de de
vocations, il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
ont envie d'y aller mais qui sont même
freinés et c'est un déchirement pour eux
par leur propre père parce que ben on a
un agriculteur qui meurt tous les deux
jours et quatre ou cin qui essayent de
se suicider tous les jours. Donc
l'espoir il y est, mais en fait pour moi
on est vraiment au bord de la falaise et
c'est maintenant qu'il faut faire
quelque chose et cette problématique
elle touche pas. En fait, si ça touchait
que les paysans, on pourrait dire
presque 400000 personnes, c'est c'est
pas la fin du monde. Je dis ça, je doute
bien que je le pense pas vraiment, mais
précisons. Mais mais en fait, c'est
catastrophique pour tous les Français
parce que si on perd la souveraineté
alimentaire, on perd toute opportunité
de révolte, de révolution ou de
changement dans ce pays. On deviendra et
on on pèsera en fait ce que pèse
aujourd'hui certains pays d'Afrique ou
du Moyen-Orient ou d'Asie qui ne sont
pas du tout autosuffisant au niveau
alimentaire et qui dépendent de de ceux
qui ouvrent les vannes pour leur vendre
la nourriture. Si on perd la
souveraineté alimentaire, c'est ça qui
nous attend. Et donc non seulement les
paysans doivent se soulever et arrêter
ce pays à mon sens, mais toute la
population et quel que soient les
opinion politiques. Parce que que tu
sois d'ultra extrême gauche, d'ultra
extrême droite, euh s'il y a plus de
souveraineté alimentaire, tu changeras
rien, tu réformeras rien parce que tu
peux prendre les armes et virer un
gouvernement, mais derrière quand il va
falloir en remettre un, c'est ceux qui
te nourrissent qui choisiront qui tu
mets en place parce que les autres, ils
auront pas accès à la bouffe. Et si tu
dois choisir entre tes opinions
politiques, tes principes aussi durs
soit-il et voir tes enfants mourir de
faim, et ben tu choisiras de sauver tes
enfants. Et c'est pour ça que ça fait
partie des des moyens de pression que la
France, les États-Unis et autres
utilisent depuis toujours pour tenir les
pays plus pauvres sous leur botte.
Voilà.
Tu dis révolte.
H
tu sais ce que ça veut dire révolte ?
Oui. Alors, la racine je ne l'ai pas,
mais euh
la révolte, c'est en fait euh on revient
on revient au même euh au même endroit.
Hm.
Il faut peut-être faire une demi-volte
renversée
au trê de de de plaisanterie pourrie.
Euh on va parler du mercour, on va
parler tout un tas de choses comme ça.
Mais avant, je vais en profiter parce
que je sais qu'on va être écouté par des
agriculteurs encore plus ce soir. À tous
les agriculteurs qui me font et qui nous
font remonter des messages, qui nous
écoutent pieusement. dans leur
moissonneuse batteuse, dans leur rang de
vigne, dans leur cave, dans avec leur
range en beurreur ou avec leur canard,
leur mouton, leur bœu. On salue
d'ailleurs Pierrinard, bœuf d'herbe qui
est un lanceur d'alerte autour de tout
ça. Et euh on vous embrasse fort et
merci pour vos gentils messages et vos
photos avec notre logo depuis des
moissonneuses batteuses, deux dingues.
et merci de nous informer sur vos
problèmes, sur tout ça. Vous êtes nos
yeux et nos oreilles et et on vous
embrasse fort et courage les gars et les
nanas aussi parce que il y en a
beaucoup.
Revenons revenons à nos à nos moutons,
si je peux dire ça tu as vu une
augmentation du prix de la bouffe pour
tes bêtes ? Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que
le prix de l'électricité tu le sens
passer ? Est-ce que autour de toi des
potes agriculteurs t'ont fait remonter
que leurs intrans parce que il y a eu de
l'inflation sur les intrans qui viennent
de Russie parce que en fait les intran
c'est du gaz.
Est-ce que comment ils gèrent ça ?
Est-ce qu'ils en parlent entre eux ?
Est-ce qu'ils essayent un petit peu de
s'informer ? Ils en parlent, ils en
parlent. Et en fait le problème qu'il y
a mais et alors là aussi je vais faire
un parallèle avec la population
française pas que le monde agricole
c'est que il y a un vrai désespoir parce
que tu vois si tu me permets une toute
petite digression avant d'y revenir moi
ce que je ressens et c'est viable pour
les paysans mais en fait je pense que
les gens qui nous écoutent quelle que
soit leur profession là-dessus en fait
on a une corde au cou et on nous la sert
millimètres par millimètre par
millimètre ce qui fait qu'on accepte
toujours un petit peu et et la situation
empire empire empire et en fait ça crée
du désespoir et donc il y en a beaucoup.
C'est pour ça aussi qu'il y a des
suicides ou des abandons parce que euh
beaucoup perdent espoir. Alors moi je je
refuse de de perdre espoir. Tu vois mon
côté extrême droite c'est peut-être de
croire à la France éternelle.
C'est pas d'extrême droite.
Non mais je sais ça pour rire mais parce
que aujourd'hui tout est extrême droite
ou extrême droite.
Le drapeau français n'est pas d'extrême
droite.
Ah non plus. On est d'accord. Mais bon
c'est c'est un vaste vaste sujet. Mais
la marseillaise n'est pas d'extrême
droite non plus.
Non plus.
Mais euh
du coup ben au niveau de
la solidarité n'est pas que d'extrême
gauche.
Ah non, le elle a pas le monopole du
cœur non plus. Non, mais bon, c'est
voilà. Merci de de l'entendre, enfin de
le dire. Euh du coup, par rapport au
prix, bah oui, sur l'énergie. Alors, sur
l'énergie, c'est complètement délirant.
Ben moi qui est euh trois chambres
froides et séchoir pour faire ma
charcuterie, je le sens passer mais je
suis petit quand je vois les amis qui
ont des stations fruitières. C'est c'est
des trucs de fou parce que c'est des
frigos bien plus bien plus importants et
tous ceux qui ont ben des besoins en
énergie électrique en France.
Et le vrai scandale, c'est que là aussi
c'est l'Europe en fait parce que c'est
la tarification à Ren en fait qui nous
qui nous met dedans par rapport au fait
que on indexe les les prix du du MAW sur
ce que fait sur les comment dire les
productions d'énergie vertes que font
les Allemands pour viabiliser pour
viabiliser le le le différences de coût
mais ce qui fait qu'au final on paye le
MGAW plus de deux fois plus cher que ce
qu'on devrait le payer logiquement et ça
n'a absolument aucun sens de fonctionner
comme ça. C'est indéfendable.
D'ailleurs, il y a certains pays
d'Europe qui sont pas dedans. L'Espagne,
le Portugal et cetera. Mais nous en
France, voilà, on est
venu dans dans le marché intégré. Non,
non, ils en sont sortis he de la R. Ah
oui, ah oui oui oui oui oui. À moins
qu'ils y soient revenus dans les 6
derniers mois à vérifier, mais il y a 6
mois en arrière, je te certifie qu'ils
étaient pas dedans.
Tu connais les les consignes de sécurité
chez nous, pas de diffamation, pas
d'énigrement, des sources triangulées
sourcé carré cubique. Pas j'ai entendu
un bruit de très important. et et sur
l'arène, j'avais vraiment étudié mon
sujet. Donc euh non, je je suis sûr de
ce que je te dis. Euh donc ben au niveau
des coûts, oui, tout augmente. Alors
moi, l'aliment euh j'ai la chance qu'il
n'augmente pas parce qu'en fait j'ai
fait un je suis même dans l'illégalité,
figure-toi. L'illégalité c'est très mal
parce qu'en France, tu n'as pas le droit
d'acheter de céréales en si tu ne passes
pas par les coopératives.
Tu fais de la filière courte. OK.
Voilà. Non, non, mais je l'explique, je
l'ai déjà dit si tu veux, c'est pas un
secret, moi je m'en fous. Il y a des
choses quand ça n'a pas de sens, je
l'assume publiquement. Euh, tu n'as pas
le droit d'acheter des céréales sans
passer par des coopératives. Les
semences, c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement tenu alors que ça n'a ni
que ni tête que ça existe. Et donc en
fait, mon voisin qui a les terres autour
de mes bois est en bio aussi, me produit
l'aliment et je le lui achète
directement. Donc ça passe de son champ
à mes silos et on a choisi de pas suivre
les cours mais de se mettre à prix fixe
sur 5 ans de manière à ce queon puisse
vivre tous les deux et qu'on ait un prix
cohérent. Donc euh moi je suis pas
impacté par ça, mais la vraie détresse
en fait au niveau de l'aliment c'est
même il y a même pas tant
d'augmentation, c'est plus c'est plus
presque l'inverse parce qu'en fait les
cours sont extrêmement bas et c'est plus
pour les producteurs de céréales que
c'est super dur parce qu'aujourd'hui tu
vends tes céréales à perte parce que le
coût de production est supérieur au prix
de vente parce que on t'inonde le marché
avec de la céréale ukrainienne
notamment. Je te parle même pas de ce
qui arrive d'Amérique du Sud et qui
arrive déjà hein parce qu'on parle du
Mercur mais les les packs beau de
céréales et autres OGM qui arrivent de
d'Amérique du Sud dans nos ports
français c'est tous les jours.
Ah je suis absolument sûr. Je peux même
te dire que la coordination rurale en a
en a attrapé un dans un port de la côte
ouest. Je sais plus lequel mais Oui oui.
Non, ça c'est sûr et certain.
Et puis si tu veux, ben le gros problème
qu'on a c'est aussi je mets toujours
l'Europe mais parce que c'est toujours
lié à ça ce qu'on nous fait avec
l'Ukraine parce qu'en fait dès qu'il y a
un problème pour l'Union européenne la
variable d'ajustement c'est les paysans
et la première puissance agricole
d'Europe c'est la France donc la
variable c'est nous sauf que on trinque
à chaque fois le mercred
Attends je vais me faire l'avocat
bien sûr
les Ukrain ils en prennent plein la
gueule avec les popof euh ils se
retrouvent sous les bombes sous les
drones sous les machins et ainsi de
suite. leur économie en train de se
vauter. L'Union européenne ouvre ses
marchés pour les aider.
Oui, mais tu es
c'est un effort de guerre. Tu es
beaucoup trop pour suivre tes émissions
depuis longtemps. Tu es malheureusement
beaucoup trop intelligent et cultivé
pour croire à ce que tu viens de me dire
puisque si on sacrifiait des paysans
français pour le petit producteur
ukrainien Jean-Vladimir qui fait du blé
ce que tu veux.
Faut toujours penser contre soi-même.
Oui. Non mais tout à fait mais on peut
on peut l'expliquer justement de manière
très cartésienne. Si c'était ça, ça
n'aurait pas de sens de sacrifier les
les paysans français pour les paysans
ukrainiens. Mais on pourrait entendre
une solidarité, quelque chose qu'on soit
mieux queux.
Impeccable, pas de souci. Sauf qu'en
fait ce qu'on importe d'Ukraine, ça
vient de colossales compagnies qui
pèsent des milliers et des milliers
d'hctares et qui sont rachetés
principalement par nos amis américains
notamment Black Rock. Et tout ce que je
dis est parfaitement sourcé, vérifiable
et cetera. Donc en fait euh on achète la
céréale que produisent les méga
compagnies américaines. En plus en
exploitant les Ukrainiens qui ont déjà
la guerre et en nous vendant des
produits. Si les gens voyaient comment
ces produits, ils n'y toucheraient pas.
Euh mais pourtant beaucoup d'entre nous,
tous ceux qui mangent des produits
transformés et cetera où il y a des
œufs, du poulet, bien souvent ça arrive
de là-bas parce qui permet d'être pas
cher. Euh et c'est dégueulasse. Et avec
le mercure, ce qui nous arrive
d'Amérique du Sud, c'est pareil.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce que j'ai
Et tu dis que c'est dégueulasse, mais
est-ce que tu as goûté ?
Mais je c'est Alors,
très très bon point. Très bon. Euh je
maintiens que c'est dégueulasse parce
que déjà sur de la viande ou des œufs si
tu veux si c'est mal produit, je ne vais
pas t'apprendre qu'un poulet si
c'est mal abattu
aussi c'est encore notre sujet c'est
vrai. Mais si c'est mal produit enfin un
poulet un poulet de d'ultra batterie
poussé au moins de jours du moins de
jours du moins de jour enfin c'est
dégueulasse. C'est c'est incomparable à
un poulet fermier et en goût et en
texture et en
un poulet de bresse
par exemple. par exemple. Donc euh donc
du coup je perds le fil
donc les importations.
Oui, voilà. Le le Mercossur si tu veux,
c'est ce que j'ai pu dire à à notre
bien-aimé Raï quand je l'ai rencontré
qui nous expliquait euh
tu parles de notre leader charismatique
et lumineux solaire.
Exactement.
Emmanuel Macron,
le fameux Emmanuel 1er.
Euh,
attendez et on va faire une petite
seconde de vénération ensemble.
Euh,
une deuxième pour son ministre.
Ah non,
Bruno Lem
Bruno. Oui, Bruno, je je la fais avec
toi. Je
Non, euh si tu veux, c'est qu'il a
commencé à essayer de nous expliquer au
début. Non, mais le mercure c'est pas
encore signé. Et je dit mais monsieur le
président, il y a JBS qui est une énorme
multinationale brésilienne de la viande
qui a même bouffé le marché
nord-américain. C'est dire quand tu
bouffes les Américains chez eux, comment
tu pèses ? euh qui a publié sur toute la
presse internationale le fait qu'ils
avaient déjà signé leurs accords
commerciaux en Europe. Donc c'est quand
même compliqué quand une société qui
pèse des milliards et des milliards et
des milliards joue à communiquer dans la
presse internationale de nous dire que
le Mercosur et puis au final il nous a
avoué déjà qu'il était totalement
promossû mondialisme libre échange et
cetera, que c'était une chance et qu'on
allait sauver notamment la viticulture
avec ça euh quand tu sais euh que le
monde agricole en fait au niveau de la
viticulture, ils font partie des plus
sinistrés en France actuellement.
C'est-à-dire que les viticulteurs, on ne
leur propose aucune solution
structurelle. Alors, quand je dis ça,
c'est des mots peut-être dur à
comprendre. Ce que je veux dire par
structurel, c'est-à-dire de restructurer
l'agricole pour proposer des nouveaux
débouchés, des nouvelles solutions,
quelque chose une vision à long terme.
Tout ce qu'on propose aux agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qui sont en VTI et qui
crèvent, c'est un plan social,
c'est-à-dire une prime à l'arrachage.
Ils arrachent leur vigne et puis après
ben soit ils abandonnent leur terre,
soit ils font autre chose. Voilà.
Je m'autorisé à faire encore l'avocat,
même si j'y crois pas une seconde, je me
dois par déontologie.
sur le Mercosour, j'ai vu passer très
récemment qu'ils ont voté une en France,
ils ont voté quelque chose pour
bah s'opposer au Mercour.
Oui, c'est sympa. C'est c'est
intéressant,
c'est cosmétique. Et la deuxième chose
Et la deuxième chose, c'est
en viticulture, il y a il y a une y
a-t-il un problème de surproduction ?
Pour moi, le problème est pas dans la
surproduction. Le problème déjà c'est
ben par exemple sur le marché américain
les taxes que notre ami Donald a pu
mettre en France, il y a eu une baisse
de consommation
mais enfin pour moi tout ça n'est pas
n'est pas inéluctable et le problème
n'est pas tant dans la surproduction que
dans la comment dirais-je dans la
commercialisation dans l'export parce
que c'était ce qui nous permettait la
viticulture de garder une balance
commerciale agricole positive en France
et pour la première fois cette année on
n plus en positif parce que la VTI
plonge
Et si tu veux, l'histoire du marché
sud-américain dit comme ça, ça a l'air
sympa. Sauf que les viticulteurs sont
pas complètement débiles. Il y en a
pas débile du tout.
Oui, il y en a il y en a qui qui s'en
sortent encore bien ou qui s'en
sortaient très bien. Donc qui cherchent
des marchés toujours, voilà, qui
cherchent à développer leur business,
c'est normal.
Comment on dit bonjour dans ta langue ?
Bonjour. Enfin, je Et
il y a pas l'argot toi du coin.
Euh, tu me poses une là, je
Ça veut dire quoi Adichas ? Adichat,
c'est adieu. C'est et c'est vrai qu'on
peut enfin adieu en français, on peut
même le dire pour dire bonjour chez
nous. Mais non, je t'avoue que j'ai
jamais euh là je Alors là, tu me fais
bugger là, tu m'as tué. Bien joué, bien
joué, bien joué.
Euh bien pour me perdre, nickel.
Mercur Vi. Oui, c'est que si tu veux
cette histoire de sauver la viticulture
avec le le marché sud-américain, c'est
une énorme plaisanterie parce que déjà
en Argentine, au Chili, ils en
produisent du vin mais surtout chez eux,
c'est pas culturel. Donc Argentine, le
pinard, ça devient culturel.
C'est pas des Ouais, mais c'est pas des
gros buveurs. Tu as pas un marché qui
est très développé au niveau et puis
surtout je te parle de l'ensemble de
l'Amérique du Sud parce que l'Argentine
c'est un pays qui produit déjà du vin.
Euh tu as les Chiliens mais les Chiliens
ils en boivent pas. Euh le Brésil c'est
c'est pas culturel chez eux. Donc donc
si tu veux tu vas pas créer un énorme
débouché pour la V.
Ils peuvent arroser leur vigne.
Oui aussi. Ouis. Bah alors l'eau est
encore un vaste et nous on n pas le
droit d'arroser nos vies.
Nous on n pas le droit de stocker l'eau.
Ça c'est encore un Alors moi sur cette
question là je suis pour qu'on puisse
stocker l'eau mais de manière en fait je
suis pas emballé par les les méga
structures qui sont contrôlées que par
des mecs qui se tiennent près du feu via
la FNSEA ou ce que tu veux ou près des
ministres ou voilà. Moi je je suis pour
qu'il y ait des que les en gros que les
paysans aient le droit de créer des
retenues d'eau limité tu vois. enfin
qu'on qu'on définisse en terme de volume
pour pouvoir avoir ce qu'on appelle des
cultures à forte valeur ajoutée euh ou
pour pouvoir arroser quel que soit leur
production. Mais voilà et et au final
même pour la pour la biodiversité en
fait, tu le vois quand tu mets quand tu
mets un point d'eau, tous les animaux
viennent y manger, y boire, euh si
rincer, si tout ce que tu veux, enfin du
coup ça crée des points vraiment de vie
pour la fun et la flore. C'est
indiscutable. Donc voilà euh la
ressource à Ouais, ça c'est encore un
énorme problème et l'un des gros
problèmes que vivent les agriculteurs en
France aujourd'hui, c'est le dénigrement
et l'assassinat même que leur font les
écolos. Parce que moi, comme je dis, je
suis en bionne hyperext, mes animaux le
la seule le seul médicament qui voit
c'est un vermifuge une fois par an. Donc
tu vois, on n'est pas sur un truc hyper
extensif, ça veut dire quoi pour ceux
qui
? Ça veut dire ça veut dire que ils ont
énormément de place. Alors gros,
ils sont pas beaucoup. C'est ça.
La densité au mètres carrés. Alors en
dans mon parc d'engraissement, il y a un
peu plus de 1000 m² par animal si je le
remplis. Et mon parc de reproduction,
c'est 5000 m² par animal. Donc voilà,
c'est pas le moins d'un m² par animal en
bâtiment si tu veux. Euh donc ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est que je suis pas
l'ayatola des engrais, des pesticides,
de tout ce que tu veux. Il en faut parce
qu'il y a des choses où on a pas de
solution. Mais euh les écolos nous tuent
parce que au nom de principes bobo où on
fait peur à la population comme avec la
la loi du plomb que je je suis pas un
fan de la loi du plom de certaines
choses qu'il y avait dedans mais le
débat sur la cétamiprine si tu veux
cette ce pesticide principalement contre
la punaise diabolique et tout pour
protéger surtout les noisettes mais pas
que euh on l'a interdit très bien mais
du coup en fait la la production de
noisette en France va crever parce qu'en
fait ça veut dire que elle te elle te
pique tes noisettes et donc en fait elle
les abîme et donc quand tu récoltes tu
jettes 50 % de ta production. Donc déjà
que te battre contre les Turcs qui sont
de gros producteurs qui ont pas les
mêmes charges sociales, les mêmes coups
de main d'œuvre et cetera, c'est une
galère. Mais si en plus eux ils ont
droit ils ont déjà droit à des produits
interdits chez nous depuis très
longtemps, mais si tu rajoutes ça, on
est mort. Et le l'incohérence c'est que
les gens ont dir non on veut pas ça,
c'est pas bien, ça tue les abeilles.
Mais déjà les apiculteurs, ils ont
jamais été vent debout contre la
cétamipride parce que leur principale
préoccupation aux apiculteurs, c'est un
parasite qui s'appelle le le varoa et
et le le frelon asiatique. Mais du coup,
pour en revenir donc à ça, en fait, le
problème c'est que les gens achètent du
Nutella, les gens achètent des produits
transformés avec des noisettes,
marqu pas de marque,
mes excuses, de la pâte à tartiner au
chocolat et à la noisette euh et des
produits divers et variés avec des
noisettes. que des noisettes
d'importation euh qui arrivent de
Turquie et qui et pas que mais
principalement de Turquie.
C Nutella, ils ont pas fait un un pot M
in France. Non.
Ah, je maîtrise pas. Je t'avoue que j'en
achète pas. Mais
moi, je posais juste la question.
Mais je je vais même te dire que à la
ministre, je lui ai je lui ai enfin
c'est même pas c'est un ami à moi qui
lui a posé la question en lui disant
"Mais pourquoi dans ces cas-là vous
fermez pas les usines Nutella ?" et elle
nous a dit "Ah non, mais si on ferme une
usine, ça va mettre des salariés au
chômage, ce qui est vrai hein, c'est pas
le problème. Mais du coup, en fait, les
paysans français qui eux crèvent euh
c'est pas grave, mais toucher une usine,
enfin bon,
je me fais encore l'avocat du diable
parce que tu mets en cause les écolos.
Les écolos quand il rallent des fois il
lèvent des scandales sanitaires, il
lèvent que nos napatiques sont des sont
pollués, que ce type d'exploitation
pollue les sols ou pollue les mers, que
les rejets agricoles ont été faits à
l'arrache, que je suis obligé de de de
Mais je suis entièrement d'accord avec
toi, mais je suis pas opposé au fait de
protéger la nature. Au contraire, euh la
pollution des naps fréatiques, c'est une
catastrophe. Tu as plus de 90 % des
nappes fréatiques en France qui sont
pollués au métau lourd. Faut être un
abruti pour pas leur donner raison sur
ces points-là. Je dis pas qu'il faut pas
protéger la nature, je dis juste que il
faut pas se suicider nous pour importer
des choses encore pire parce qu'en plus
les produits qui font des milliers de
kilomètres euh dans des gros tankers et
autres, enfin le bilan carbone et tout
ce que tu veux fait au niveau écologie,
ça n'a ni que ni tête. Donc il faut nous
proposer des solutions. Et le problème
qu'ont les écolos, c'est un d'être
absolument contre les frontières et pour
l'Europe et ce que tu veux.
Sauf que si tu n'as pas de frontière, si
tu contrôles pas ce qui entre dans ton
pays au niveau des marchandises, tu ne
peux pas protéger chez toi. Si chez nous
tues la production, mais tout ce que tu
fais c'est tuer la production. Mais la
consommation restera la même. Donc on va
juste importer pire et tu vas permettre
qu'on mette plus de saloperie dans
d'autres pays. Donc ton raisonnement
est à la fois stupide. C'est même pas
égoïste, c'est même pire qu'égoïste
parce qu'en fait du coup tu t'en fous
que les Turcs ils s'empoisonnent encore
plus. Enfin, il faut proposer des
solutions si tu veux. Voilà. Euh et donc
je disais euh ça et après ben bon, il y
a un autre sujet, c'est aussi la chasse
où les chasseurs sont les à mon sens en
tout cas les premiers écologistes dans
ce pays parce que les gens oublient ou
ne savent pas que par exemple quand il y
a des dégâts dans les cultures liés aux
sangliers, c'est les dianes de chasse
qui payent. enfin les les ACCA euh et
les gens oublient ça. Les gens oublient
que les chasseurs c'est ceux qui
protègent justement ben nos culture euh
et qui régulle la faune sauvage. Et euh
les les délires sur le loup et l'our si
tu veux si on les a éliminé, c'est pas
parce que c'est pas Coca-Cola, c'est pas
le grand méchant capitalisme, c'est
juste que quand on a été suffisamment
équipé, on s'en est débarrassé parce que
quand tu vis avec c'est pas rigolo en
fait. Et et si tu veux, ça j'en profite
que je suis chez toi pour le dénoncer
aussi. c'est que l'ours si tu veux, bon
c'est regrettable qu'on ait éteint un
l'ours des Pyrénées. Moi, je suis pas
compte que tu prennes deux ou trois
montagnes, tu les tu les fermes et tu en
fais des réserves à loup ou à ours si tu
as envie, pourquoi pas ? Mais euh
d'amener des ourses slovenes, d'amener
une poignée qui se reproduisent entre
eux qui sont consanguins au dernier
degré pour que quand Christian va faire
une randonnée dans les Pyrénées une fois
tous les 4 ans et puisse peut-être voir
un ours, ça n'a ni que ni tête. quand tu
vois comment ça massacre les cheptel ce
que ça fait et derrière en plus comment
ça se passe au niveau des des
indemnisations et tout parce que tu peux
avoir des animaux morts quand c'est en
estive sur des kilomètres et là ils vont
pas jouer aller chercher les les gens de
comment on appelle ça
euh de la police de l'environnement si
tu veux enfin moi j'ai eu des j'ai déjà
eu des bergers l'ONF voilà j'ai j'ai
déjà eu des bergers qui m'ont pleuré
dans les bras parce qu'ils avaient
arrêté parce que bah ils avaient eu des
des massacres comme ça causés par
l'ours, je dis bien par l'ours. et que
ben en fait les gars venus relever les
cadavres et compter les cadavres ne
voulaient pas fouiller toutes les
styles. Ce que je comprends, ça prend
une semaine s'ils veulent tout fouiller.
Mais du coup, c'est eux qui sont marrons
à la fin et puis c'est hyper
traumatisant. C'est voilà, on va pas
rentrer dans Mais entre ça et le loup
qui monte maintenant, il y en a partout
en France et de plus en plus les gens,
ils vont comprendre que le loup c'est
pas c'est un animal sauvage. C'est pas
gentil. La nature elle est pas gentille
hein. C'est
je je me refais encore l'avocat
du diable ou pas du diable. On dit
souvent les chasseurs comme nous on a
connu a pu beaucoup maintenant les
perdri les faisants, ils sont élevés en
batterie et ensuite le dimanche c'est du
bal trap.
Alors une fois de plus une fois de plus
je vais te donner raison
alors je je n'ai rien contre les gars
qui élèvent du du gibier ou quoi que ce
soit. Moi je t'avoue que ça me dépasse
le fait de lâcher du gibier d'élevage
qui en plus est stérilisé parce que
sinon c'est pas drôle, il pourrait se
reproduire. Donc euh du coup, il y a
même pas de de possibilité de
repeuplement et euh et effectivement,
c'est du tir au pigeon parce que tu les
vois les faisants d'élevage quand ils
sont lâchés, tu les as au bord de la
route, ils sont amorphe, ils bougent
pas, enfin c'est ils cherchent le grain
quoi. C'est ça, je suis d'accord avec
toi que c'est délirant. Maintenant, la
problématique du sanglier euh, elle est
réelle. Et si les gens savent pas ce que
c'est un troupeau de 30, 40 sangliers ou
comme dans des pays où il y a plus le
contrôle dessus, 200 sangliers qui
arrivent, les dégâts que ça fait, si les
gens se rendent pas compte, euh bah
c'est qu'en fait ils sont déconnectés
que ce serait bien qu'ils aillent voir
le terrain, qu'ils aillent voir les
dégâts que ça fait, ce que ça coûte. Il
y a, je vais te donner un exemple tout
bête quand je te disais que les Dianes
de chasse payent les dégâts.
J'ai un ami paysan qui est arboriculteur
qui a la chance de s'en sortir pas trop
mal, qui a eu des dégâts colossaux faits
par le chevreuil. Il a refusé que la la
Fédération de chasse paye parce que
sinon il tuait une diane de chasse en
fait parce qu'il avait 20000 € de dégâts
sur ses arbres, tu vois. Euh voilà, j'ai
pas besoin de dire son nom ni quoi que
ce soit, mais pour t'expliquer euh voilà
les ben tout ce qui va être servidé,
donc euh tous les grands cres, après les
les chevreuils, ça fait énormément de
dégâts aussi. Et alors la régulation
naturelle si vous voulez, hein, mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut des dizaines de
milliers d'ours, des centaines de
milliers de loups. Mais est-ce que les
gens réalisent que c'est un ours qui
rentre dans ton jardin en fait ? Ah,
c'est sûr, dans Paris, dans un immeuble,
tu vas pas avoir de problème avec
l'ours. Mais si tu as un jardin, si tu
as ton gamin qui se fait arracher la
tête par un ours ou ton chien ou ce que
tu veux, il s'en fout. Moi si j'ai rien,
j'ai pas de haine contre les ourses mais
demain il y a un ours dans mon jardin,
j'ai mis un coup de 12 sans discuter.
Est-ce qu'il faudrait pas revenir comme
faisaient nous aïeux avoir un chien de
berger, un patou,
un berger du Caucase ou un truc qui
ressemble à quelque chose ?
Je suis d'accord avec toi. J'en ai les
bergers en non mais ça suffit pas
toujours. Ça suffit pas toujours parce
que les estives, les animaux peuvent
s'étaler, peuvent ça dépend si tu veux.
Il y a beaucoup de c'est c'est c'est
vachement plus compliqué que ça parce
qu'avec le vivant, tu n'as jamais de
règles bien précises et puis après faut
que ton chien soit là, faut que ton
chien soit toujours en bonne forme, faut
voilà, c'est revenons à à la production
alimentaire.
Qu'est-ce que tu pourrais dire au bout
de l'assiette, c'est-à-dire au bout du
couteau, au bout de la fourchette,
quel quel va être l'impact si nos
agriculteurs ils cannent en terme de
prix, de qualité, de disponibilité ?
Comment ça va se passer ?
Ben si nos agriculteurs cannent,
ben je pense qu'en fait en terme de
prix, bon la grande distribution fera
pas de cadeaux. Donc il y aura peut-être
une baisse légère, mais j'y crois pas
trop parce qu'il comp ils se gaverront
juste encore plus comme ils ont toujours
fait.
Mais c'est surtout en terme,
c'est ton point de vue
bien sûr, mais que je peux argumenter.
Euh,
un exemple technique aussi que je peux
donner chez nous, il y a il y a deux
oui, c'était il y a 2 ans si je dis pas
de bêtises, très mauvaise année pour la
prune, les prunes les prunes partaient
en dessous de 50 centimes du kilo. Euh,
on les a retrouvé à Lyon, les prunes de
chez nous, hein, à 5 € du kilo. Donc si
tu veux et et des fois des trucs de
l'ordre de voilà 50 60 centimes ou dans
nos supermarchés dans notre propre
département tu était déjà à 3 qu balles
du kilo. C'est complètement délirant si
tu veux. Donc voilà. Non c'est mais bon
il y a il y a le transportou
il y a la l'achatendage.
Oui
oui ouais ok ça justifie pas ça. On le
sait tous les deux mais non c'est c'est
pas si tu veux je dis pas qu'il faut pas
que les intermédiaires mangent. C'est
pas le problème. Je dis juste que le
problème c'est qui se gave à la fin,
comment l'argent part dans les filiales.
Mais ça la grande distribution, on
pourrait en parler mais c'est un très
vaste sujet si on veut pas si on veut
pas enfoncer des portes ouvertes en
disant n'importe quoi. Voilà, il faut
prendre le temps d'en parler. Mais c'est
un sujet hyper important. En fait, moi
la vraie chose qui m'inquiète si tu
veux, c'est que le premier médicament,
c'est ton alimentation. C'est ce que tu
rentres dans ton corps. Et si tu rentres
brésilien et compagnie,
tu en as rentré beaucoup des
médicaments,
mais tu peux parler
mais
commence pas à m'énerver. tu vas t'en
prendre une.
Mais euh non, au niveau comment
dirais-je ? En fait, on va rentrer des
produits ultra chimique, ultra
transformé qui feront des milliers de
kilomètres. Donc l'impact
environnemental et l'impact sur nos
santé va être catastrophique. C'est
juste évident en fait. Enfin, il te
suffit de regarder les taux, on voit
l'obésité chez nous, mais regarde les
taux d'obésité dans un pays comme le
Brésil qui pourtant n'est pas riche.
C'est une catastrophe et les problèmes
de santé qu' peuvent avoir derrière. Euh
donc non effectivement il y aura encore
plus de pesticides, encore moins de
contrôle.
Et là là tu compares les choux et les
les poireaux là parce que en Amérique du
Sud l'obésité elle vient certes de la
bouffe ultra transformé.
Oui mais du sucre aussi mais c'est que
sur des boissons ultra sucré je sais pas
si tu connais un peu l'Argentine.
Il il s'arrose pas pas avec du vin de
salta mais il s'arrose au Fanta et puis
1 L par personne par repas. Oui oui, je
suis d'accord avec toi. Mais c'est qu'en
fait on va aller vraiment vers une
alimentation
qui va baisser en gamme parce que la
force de l'agriculture française si tu
veux c'est d'être la la l'agriculture
connue dans le monde pour sa qualité
plus haut de gamme si tu veux pour
vraiment avoir des beaux produits, des
bons produits sans sans comment dire
sans prétention. C'est vraiment
mondialement reconnu. Et là, en fait, on
va vraiment baisser en qualité gustative
et sanitaire et et c'est c'est juste une
évidence si tu veux. On va donner les
clés du camion à des énormes
multinationales supraétatiques.
Exactement ce qu'on ne veut pas si on
veut avoir un peu de liberté dans ce
pays. Et
ça c'est pas possible en fait.
Tu t'es mis à la place du politique qui
doit gérer un état avec une inertie.
Fais attention parce que mon ingénieur
du son, il va gueuler si tu frottes le
micro.
Est-ce que tu t'es mis à la place du
politique qui a une population
qui a un salaire qui baisse, un pouvoir
d'achat qui baisse ? Est-ce que le fait
que bah cette fuite en avant de faire
baisser baisser baisser baisser les
coups pour maintenir une population avec
ses 2200 calories par jour ? Est-ce que
toi les produits que tu vends du super
haut de gamme, du super bien travaillé,
du super bien élevé,
celui qui est à 950 balles par mois ou
1450 balles par mois, il peut peut-être
pas se les acheter.
Ah mais je ne te dis pas l'inverse, je
te dis pas qu'il y a pas ce problème
aussi de coût, mais le problème vient
aussi de comment on consomme. Parce
qu'en France, tu sais bien qu'on
consomme. Et moi le premier. Et je pense
que toi aussi
on consomme beaucoup trop de viande.
Ah non.
Oui.
Alors toi non. Bon ben tant mieux. Moi
moi je mange des poischiches.
Pas que je arrêter là.
Je mange liquide aussi.
D'accord.
Comme toi. Non
aussi mais non sans sans sans rigoler.
Euh [__] je perds le fil. Excuse-moi.
Oui. Non mais c'est bien, c'est bien. Tu
me déstabilises. Mais euh
la qualité, le manger le manger cinq
fruits et légumes par jour, on va dire.
Mais mais tu prends un pays comme
l'Italie par exemple, il mange 3000 fois
plus de légumes que nous et il mange
beaucoup moins de viande. Et en fait, le
vrai problème, c'est qu'on mange
beaucoup trop de viande par rapport à ce
que toutes les professionnels de santé
nous recommandent en terme d'apport.
Donc à nous d'en manger moins et mieux.
Et et et tout bêtement, si au lieu de
manger tous les jours un steak haché euh
premier prix de merde, euh tu manges de
la viande deux fois par semaine, tu peux
te payer une entrecôte en fait. Alors
peut-être pas au restaurant, mais chez
ton bouché, oui, ça reviendra au même
prix. Euh donc si tu veux, je pense
qu'il y a vraiment des habitudes
alimentaires à revoir. Et alors nos
politiques si tu veux, moi à un moment
donné ces gens, alors j'ai beaucoup de
mal avec les partis politiques, je suis
plutôt apolitique en fait. Euh moi ce
qui nous la fuite en avant, le
nivellement par le bas, je les supporte
plus en fait. Le nivellement par le bas,
c'est l'un des cancers de ce pays. Euh
oui, mais c'est pire à côté. Mais on
s'en tape que ce soit pire à côté. On
veut que ce soit mieux chez nous. On
veut pas que ce voilà, c'est tout. Donc
si tu veux euh oui, il faut des des
politiques de santé pour apprendre aux
gens à mieux manger et donc au final à
pas s'en sortir si cher que ça. Il faut
amener les gens. Alors bien sûr les
Parisiens, les gens des énormes villes,
je comprends que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile.
Désolé de t'avoir fait venir dans cette
ville qui se transforme en New Plus,
tu as mis plus de 35 minutes pour faire
3 4 km.
3 km, ouais, c'est ça. Mais euh
donc je te disais, il faut des
politiques de santé, il faut revoir
complètement le système de la grande
distribution. Ça c'est fondamental et ça
réglerait beaucoup de problèmes, même de
problèmes de bourse pour les gens.
Euh voilà, tu vois, sans être sans être
Carl Marx, on peut envisager ben sur le
la grande distribution, on pourrait
envisager que l'État mette un peu son
nez dedans pour faire des choses très
différentes et que je sais pas, pour moi
l'eau, l'air que tu respires, l'eau que
tu bois et la bouffe euh
dire que c'est un droit, je sais pas,
mais si quand même, peut-être que c'est
un droit quand même d'arriver à manger à
ta fin en France et et je trouve que
c'est des choses que l'État devrait
beaucoup plus encadrer, voire même
pourquoi pas gérer en fait au niveau des
réseaux de grande distribution, ça
pourrait s'envisager, ça pourrait se
penser, mais non voilà. En tout cas, moi
vraiment la fuite en avant non. Et pour
les gens qui veulent manger énormément
de viande et le reste, ben chacun fait
bien ce qu'il veut. Euh je comprends que
c'est dur quand on gagne moins d'argent.
J'ai eu passé des années dans une galère
épouvantable, donc je sais ce que c'est.
Mais euh
si tu veux, si tu choisis de manger
énormément de viande tous les jours, de
boire des sodas, de boire et de manger
de la merde, et ben tu peras la facture.
Tu peras la facture à la fin et tu le
sais quoi. C'est tout.
Je vais te demander quand même de
défendre un peu la grande distribution.
Euh, on a reçu ici euh le grand patron
de Systemu.
Ouais. qui essae quand même de faire
vivre des agriculteurs à côté de chez
lui, de choper des filières courtes, de
proposer des bons produits en marque
distributeur euh avec du lait acheté au
bon prix qui qui paye quand même
rémunère correctement le producteur de
lait. Tu vois ça des initi ? Je vois que
ça te fait marrer. Fais attention parce
que si tu te marres trop, je le fais
venir, je l'appelle tout de suite hein.
Je t'avoue que j'ai pas bien peur mais
euh
il est très sympa. Je pense qu'il y a
peut-être quelque chose à faire.
J'ai de haine contre personne. Je vais
pas prêter des intentions à ce monsieur
que je connais pas. Mais si tu veux,
tous les supermarchés le font dans nos
campagnes. En tout cas partout, tu as
au-dessus des caisses, tu as des photos
avec des paysans. Lui il amène tel
produit, lui il amène tel produit. Mais
c'est quel pourcent des rayons ? En
fait, le problème que je vois là-dedans,
c'est que oui, bien sûr, factuellement,
ils vont permettre à quelques familles
d'agriculteurs de s'en sortir. OK. Mais
il les utilise comme comme
produit d'appel, si tu veux.
C'est ton interprétation. Ah oui oui.
Ben le si tu veux dans un système
capitaliste euh à un moment donné enfin
si les grands patrons de supermarché
sont pas des des des grands capitaliste
avec euh un certain cerveau et des et de
longues dents. Euh bon moi je veux bien
Blanche-Neige mais euh voilà. Tu
fais bien Blanche-Neige dis donc.
Ouais je ouais
je te verrai plus en père Noël mais
effectivement je te remercie.
Tu as commencé hein.
Non c'est toi mais c'est pas grave.
Attention hein, tu fais peut-être un peu
plus grand que moi, mais je peux te
challenger.
C'est vrai.
Allez, on se on se on se reconcentre un
petit peu.
Je je vais te livrer une angoisse qu'on
a parce que tu sais, vu que tu nous as
dit que tu suivais un peu notre chaîne
depuis certain nombre de d'années, on a
quand même une petite angoisse avec des
gens qui se
popérisent. On voit des étudiants qui
peuvent pas bouffer. On voit les restos
du cœur crouler vers des demandes. On
voit des gens pratiquement manger de la
pâtée pour chien en guise de pâté parce
que ils ont pas un radis. On voit les
étudiants faire la queue pour des colis
alimentaires.
Ils ont pas un radis. Pour certaines les
pauvres, elles sont obligées de se
prostituer pour pouvoir survivre. On
voit des des gens dans la rue de plus en
plus.
Les agriculteurs, ils peuvent nous
sauver de ça ou bien ?
Ben, est-ce que les agriculteurs peuvent
nous nous sauver de ça ? En fait, si tu
veux, c'est au-delà c'est au-delà de la
responsabilité des agriculteurs. Les
agriculteurs en France aujourd'hui, ils
peuvent nous garantir la souveraineté
alimentaire.
Si et si on a des politiques
ambitieuses, on peut même refaire
refaire exploser la population agricole
et installer beaucoup de gens. Ça, ce
serait fondamental. Maintenant, la
gestion des prix, la gestion de comment
sont faites les choses, comment est
organisé la grande distribution, euh ça
c'est aux mains de l'État en fait. Euh
les paysans à l'heure actuelle, ils sont
tous surendettés. Et quand je te dis
tous, c'est c'est pas 100 % mais c'est
une immense partie des agriculteurs qui
sont extrêmement endettés. Puis
des fois, ils sont saisis.
Exactement. Et et je peux te dire
qu'avec avec la l'association que j'ai
que j'ai monté, on n'est pas les seuls
en France he mais on essaie d'en aider
un paquet justement à intervenir avec
les huissiers, les machins. C'est
terrible. C'est terrible. Mais ça c'est
pas quelque chose qui est de la
responsabilité des agriculteurs dans un
monde où on contrôle pas les frontières
et où on suit des cours et où on a en
plus un système de pack qui est une
connerie sans nom euh qui fait que dont
les agriculteurs ne voulaient pas. En
plus, il faut voir les manifes qu'il y a
eu en 92 quand même. Euh
et où en fait c'est juste vu qu'en gros
tu vends à perte, on te donne ça et ça
permet de gagner même pas un SMIC en
fait pour la la plupart des des paysans.
Euh
on parle même pas de la retraite.
Non mais là non,
c'est même pas la peine d'aborder ces
sujets. On va pas on va pas parler de la
MSA aujourd'hui. C'est pas le voilà.
Mais
non, non, je te dis ça, ça pour moi
vraiment cette question-là, c'est au
pouvoir public de et aux gens qui nous
dirigent en fait de de prendre des
décisions parce que la lutte contre la
en fait là déjà il y a un vrai problème
de lutte contre la pauvreté et ça c'est
pas de ressort des paysans mais avec un
système, tu vois par exle pour la PAC,
la France donne plus à l'Europe que ne
revient au paysans. Donc en fait, ça
veut dire que rien que là, il y a des
milliards à aller chercher en fait. Et
la Pâque, elle est ponctionnée par un
nombre d'organismes et de gens qui ne
sont pas agriculteurs. Il y a même eu un
théâtre à Paris qui a reçu une
subvention via le féader, je crois qu'
je crois que c'est le Féader qui
s'appelle qui est un un
avec des je crois.
Oui oui. Non non non mais je je sais
qu'il y a eu cette subvention. Je te dis
juste sur le je te dis juste sur le
Féader. Je crois que c'est le Féader à
90 %. Je suis pas sûr que ça le fait,
mais je crois pour ça que je dis je
crois euh en fait dans le ils arrivent à
trouver si tu veux des des à cocher des
cases pour justifier que de l'argent
aille. Tu as eu des bâtiments, tu as eu
et tu as énormément de de par exle de
grosses compagnies aussi qui récupèrent
l'argent de la Pâque. Le premier
pourvoyeur de Pâqu jusqu'à ce qu'il
quitte l'Union européenne, c'était le
roi d'Angleterre. Euh
c'est quoi ta source ?
Ah ben c'est officiel, tu peux aller
vérifier, c'est officiel. Euh à l'heure
actuelle en Europe, l'un des premiers
c'est le prince de Monaco. Tu vois,
je vais vérifier où.
Euh, tu peux vérifier
parce que attention euh tu peux aller
vérifier frère, je te crois. Euh,
attention, hein.
Ah ben alors euh tu me demandes alors si
tu veux, je suis pas je Non mais tu es
bon, tu es très bon mais je suis pas
arrivé ici en
sert à rien de me caresser le poil.
Ah non, je te caresse pas dans le sens
du poil. Je te dis c'est bien parce que
tu me déstabilises et tu lèves des
points mais c'est vérifiable bah avec
Google en fait en allant voir c'est plus
que de notoriété publique que de dire
que le roi d'Angleterre était le premier
pourvoyeur de pâqu en Europe. Mais je
vais te dire même dans mon département
tu as des des stations fruitières ou des
grands groupes qui prennent des millions
d'euros de Pâqu. Moi, si tu veux, je
voudrais que la PAC ce soit quelque
chose si elle existe ou si on sort de
l'Europe et qu'on voit quelque chose
pour aider le monde agricole, il faut
que ce soit plafonné. C'est-à-dire
plafonner un certain nombre d'hectares.
J'ai rien contre le fait que tu
réussisse et que tu es une énorme
exploitation. Mais si tu as une énorme
exploitation et que tu roules, en fait,
tu n'as pas besoin de de ça si tu veux.
Le principe de ces fonds, c'est
d'arriver à sauvegarder des fermes, des
petites fermes qui travaillent bien et
voilà. Et de de garantir des prix en
fait. C'est c'est ça.
Est-ce que tu regardes le système
agricole chinois ? Est-ce que toi qui
est éleveur de de cochon, est-ce que tu
vois leur leur immeuble leur immeuble à
cochon pour les protéger des maladie
pour ils ont carrément des étages à
cochon. Ça fait combien ? 10 15 20
étages plus.
C'est l'avenir, c'est pas l'avenir,
c'est une nécessité par rapport à
l'inertie et la fonction exponentielle
de croissance de leur économie ou de
leur population ou des désirs de la
population à manger de la viande.
Est-ce que tu as étudié ça ? Est-ce que
tu as essayé de voir les autres
tendances mondiales en terme de
production ? Parce que quand je
t'entends, tu fais raisonner mon petit
cœur de gaulois, mon petit cœur de le
goût du lait.
Quand on allait traire les vaches, c'est
autre chose. Quand on allait goûter la
bidoche qui était pas aspergée après
l'abattage des qui était vraiment abattu
dans le calme, la viande qui était pas
stressée avec la viande passée au
torchon, bon c'est peut-être moins
hygiénique et puis tu peux pas étendre
ça étendre ça à toute une population qui
mange autant de viande. Mais la tendance
mondiale, c'est pas le gaulois, c'est
l'ultra
mécanisation, l'ultravage des bâtiments
climatisés de 10, 15, 20 étages en
Chine. Bon, tu me diras que le parti
communiste, ils ont leur petitte ferme
bio pour eux, mais la population
générale c'est taqué taquier taqué.
Alors ben te dire que j'ai
particulièrement étudié le modèle
chinois, ce serait mentir, mais on
connaît si tu veux les méthodes des
Chinois ou des Indiens ou tu vois ce
côté hyper productif,
très déshumanisé, tu vois, surtout avec
les Chinois. Euh
bon, moi comment te dire que ça me fait
penser l'étape d'après, c'est Soleil
Vert en fait, si tu veux. Donc voilà,
moi ça c'est Soleil Vert pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas la référence
cinématographique, c'est un classique du
cinéma où en fait on comment dirais-je,
on recycle, on va dire les les cadavres
pour faire de l'alimentation. En fait,
tu veux une petite anecdote, tu disais
que le premier médicament c'était
l'alimentation.
Ouais.
Je demande à me faire fact checker par
la communauté. Paraît-il que dans les
cimetières, on a des problèmes de
décomposition de cadavres humain parce
que il y a tellement de conservateurs de
tout ça. Alors, je demande à à me faire
sourcer ça, c'est c'est peut-être une
hallucination de mon cerveau, mais tu
m'as fait penser à pe c'est très
cohérente, ne serait-ce que par rapport
aussi au tanatopracteur en fait au à la
façon dont on prépare les corps. Il y a
100 ans en arrière, on faisait pas ça.
ont enterrer plus rapidement. Voilà.
Mais ça, je n'ai pas je ne je ne
maîtrise pas ce problème. Mais mais
après sur les Chinois et le reste si tu
veux, en fait la vraie question c'est
pas qu'est-ce qu'ils font eux parce
qu'en fait il faut qu'on soit un petit
peu réaliste quand on nous dit oui,
comment on va concurrencer la Chine ?
Mais les gars, enfin il faut être un peu
réaliste. La France va pas redevenir la
première puissance du monde. Mais la
France elle a des qualités. On n pas en
fait on n pas de toute façon le problème
qu'on a c'est qu'on a plus factuellement
on a plus de colonie et on n pas de de
matière première. Donc euh pour contrer
les terres rares chinoises,
le comment on appelle ça ?
Oui. Non non, je voulais parler aussi de
du du de ce qu'on met pour faire
fonctionner nos centrales nucléaires.
Euh voilà,
l'uranium euh voilà les diamants, l'or,
le pétrole, le gaz, même si on a trouvé
un peu de gaz dans les Pyrénées, mais
bon euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à ça ?
Bon mais sur ça, il faut trouver en fait
si tu veux je pense qu'il y a des
choses, ce n'est pas le seul modèle,
mais moi, un pays où il y a pas mal de
choses dont j'aimerais qu'on s'inspire,
c'est la Suisse. Et pour cette histoire
de contrôle des frontières, parce que
ils le font ça à la semaine.
Cette semaine, il manque des carottes et
des fraises. Cette semaine, on importe
des carottes et des fraises. La semaine
d'après, il manque des salades, on
importe des salades. l'idée des Suisses
et sur l'aspect démocratique aussi avec
ce côté référendum et vraie démocratie
qu'on n pas chez nous parce que chez
nous on vote pas puisqu'on
Ouais mais chez nous on est lit on vote
pas
et voilà eux ils votent
revenons revenons à l'agriculture aux
paysans et aux agriculteurs ce qui est
d'ailleurs le même terme je je dirais
les syndicat comment ça se passe pour
défendre vos vos vos intérêts, vos
business, vos santé, vos comment vous
êtes défendu. Alors, tu me diras toi, tu
es dans un syndicat. Tu es dans quel
syndicat toi ?
Coordination rurale.
C'est c'est les boulins jaunes.
Voilà.
Ah, c'est c'est les dangereux.
Ah, c'est des fous furieux. C'est c'est
c'est
c'est le bruit des bottes.
Alors, je te pose la question, mais je
vais un peu meubler juste avant. Est-ce
que tu as suivi comment les agriculteurs
étaient en train de monter à Paris la
dernière fois ?
Oui,
c'était des jeunes ce coup-ci. C'était
des jeunes euh avec une un vocabulaire
pratiquement militaire.
Hm hm.
C'était nous quand on a vu la monté euh
de nos paysans euh sur la capitale,
quand il faisait des barrages sur les
autoroutes où il montaient des ballots
de paille, pas n'importe où. Je donnerai
pas, tu veux que je donne mon mon
interprétation des ballots de paille ?
Bien sûr.
Le béton quand il crame, en général, il
faut le refaire derrière. Et j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il connaissait la
formule.
Ça te fait mar que les paysans ils
savent bricoler. Je suis surpris.
Commence pas. Donc là ça ça m'a fait
sentir du désespoir chez eux. Du
désespoir à tel point qu'ils étaient
prêts à se militariser
pour défendre leur leur business, leur
vie, leur famille, leur culture paysane.
Est-ce que tu penses que ça peut
dégénérer ? Oui.
Ah oui oui oui. Je pense je pense et je
crois et j'ai même envie de te dire
quelque part que j'espère
parce qu'il faut pas. Non non mais
c'est pas ça, c'est qu'en fait on n'est
pas des chiens et qu'il vaut mieux
mourir debout que vivre à genou. Donc je
préfère que ça finisse mal mais qu'on
parte avec les honneurs que qu'on meure
au bout d'une corde si tu veux. Moi, je
vais te dire, ben j'ai plein de copains
qui étaient dans la montée en tracteur
puisque c'est parti de 30 km de chez
moi, c'est parti d'Agin de la SR47 et
des plein de gens les ont rejoint en
chemin. Euh
au 2024 sur cette même année, on a eu un
moment d'union sacrée, on va dire, entre
les syndicats au salon de l'agriculture
contre Macron. C'est là que je m'étais
fait remarquer, dirons-nous, avec les
CRS.
Comment tu t'étais fait remarquer encore
? Ben, en poussant la CRS8 et en passant
à travers les CRS. Oui,
c'était moi le grand con avec ce que je
t'ai dit quand on a notre type de
physique, il faut faire gaffe parce que
ça peut terminer vite en cours d'assise.
Tu es au courant ?
Mais et les CRS, ils sont gentils.
Mais les CRS c'est pas l'histoire parce
qu'après bon, on va me dire "Oui, mais
ils ont éborné, je sais pas qui." Oui,
oui, c'est vrai. Il y a pas que des gens
bien dans la police mais pour les pour
les mais la majeure partie pense comme
nous, ils sont à bout, ils sont rentrés
pour ce qu'ils avaient envie de protéger
la population et de servir. Et il faut
arrêter. En fait, moi ce qui m'énerve
avec le truc antiflic, c'est qu'il y a
aucun modèle de société viable sans les
flics. Ça n'existe pas. Sinon, on se met
des coups de hache dès qu'on a un
désaccord. Donc oui, il y a des
inconvénients. Oui, quand tu les as en
face, alors que tu défends une cause
juste, ça fout les boules. Mais eux, ils
les ont aussi. Et moi, j'ai déjà vu en
face de moi des mobiles en armure avec
les larmes qui coulaient parce qu'ils
étaient en face de nous. Ça ça fait
quelque chose. Mais tu vois, en début
d'année, on a essayé de remonter à
Paris, on a eu droit à des forces de
l'ordre XXL en face de nous. Euh
mais si tu veux ce désespoir les mecs,
en fait tout le monde va pas partir en
se mettant le le fusil dans la bouche
hein.
Il y en a qui vont partir en le tournant
vers ceux qui les font crever hein. Pas
faire ça.
Non mais je dis pas qu'il faut faire ça
mais je dis qu'à force de jouer avec la
misère et de faire crever les gens et de
les pousser au désespoir, si tu es
désespéré,
je comprends totalement ce genre de de
move. Si tu veux,
quand les agriculteurs étaient montés à
Paris, le truc qui nous a fait mourir de
rire, c'est quand les agriculteurs ont
dépanné les vabbes euh parce que les
vabes étaient tellement vieux et il y
avait que les agriculteurs pour les
dépanner.
Euh un Vap, ça se soulève avec un
tracteur ou bien ?
Ah bah, ça dépend de la taille du
tracteur. Mais oui, oui, oui. Mais c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui les c'est ce qui les
emmerde aussi, c'est que
Mais ça emmerde aussi les agriculteurs
parce que c'est leur travail de travail.
Mais c'est ça, c'est mais moi si tu veux
ben quand on a essayé de monter à Paris
et qu'on était nassé, moi j'avais des
mecs à bout qui étaient en train de
couler qui pleuraient de rage et qui
voulaient aller péter dans les flics
avec leur tracteur.
Et ça à gérer c'est quelque chose hein.
C'est c'est je t'assure que c'est
prenant ça, c'est quelque chose parce
que tu veux pas que le mec détruise sa
vie. Parce que bien sûr que les les les
sentor et le reste si on décide de
sacrifier les tracteurs, on les
retourne. Mais les mecs après, ils
perdent de tout. Parce que cette légende
que tuas en France, oui mais regarde le
paysan, il a un tracteur à 200000 € il a
des terres mais il est endetté à un
point. Tu les gens se rendent pas compte
en fait. Tout est à crédit, tout est
artificiel en fait. Et c'est là que j'en
veux énormément à la grande
distribution. Et ça, même si ce monsieur
de Superrueu est peut-être quelqu'un de
formidable, il pourra pas me dire
l'inverse, c'est que c'est eux les
responsables du fait qu'on soit passé à
une agriculture beaucoup plus
industrielle. parce qu'en fait tu
produisais des pommes, on on vient te
voir, on te dit "OK, je t'achète tes
pommes." Par contre, il me faut beaucoup
plus de volume, donc je suis prêt à te
les payer un super prix, mais l'année
prochaine, il me faut 10 fois plus de
pommes. Alors bon, en pomme, il faudrait
planter les arbres, c'est plus long,
mais tu comprends l'idée. Donc les mecs,
euh que ce soit en élevage ou autres, se
mécanisent, font d'énormes
investissements, achètent des terres,
plantent, produisent et quand ils ont la
cam et qu'ils sont l'accord de coût, et
ben là, on baisse les prix.
Et là, si tu veux continuer à t'en
sortir, sauf que tu fais quasiment zéro
marge, et ben il faut produire encore
plus. Donc t'endêter encore plus et puis
ben vient le moment où ben tu finis
pendu dans ta grange parce que tu
arrives plus. Et ça c'est une [__] de
réalité et ça c'est la faute de la
grande distribution. On peut me raconter
ce qu'on veut, c'est factuel et c'est
sur ça que je leur en veux parce que le
petit paysan à qui ils prennent sa
production pour afficher sa tête dans le
supermarché et faire semblant de faire
du local, c'est lui pour ce gars-là,
c'est très bien. Mais tous ceux à qui
ont fait produire énormément et qui
dépendent des cours et qui dépendent du
tel fond, telle grossiste va décider tel
prix, tel vie. Là, on est on voit bien
que ça couvre dans la la France paysane.
On voit que on comme on est connecté
avec toutes les régions parce qu'on a
des gens partout et des gens qui nous
suivent depuis des années nous font
remonter de l'information, du
renseignement de terrain, c'est nos
sondes, nos yeux, nos oreilles, ils nous
offrent l'ubiquité.
On a accès aux photos, vidéos, à tout un
tas de choses. On sent que ça couvre.
On sent aussi d'autres paramètres comme
tu sais, on travaille sur la finance,
sur la stabilité monétaire, sur la
géopolitique, sur les espèces de
guerres, sur tout un tas de choses, des
flux migratoires, le réchauffement
climatique, la disponibilité en eau et
je t'en passe et je t'en passe et je
t'en passe.
Là, ça couvre furieusement. H
j'ai j'ai Est-ce que le gouvernement mis
à part notre leader suprême suprême et
lumineux et solaire Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'il est venu autrement prendre
ou envoyer ses émissaires
pour être proactif
pour
Benah il nous a rencontré
il y a eu une seule rencontre avec le
monde agricole et Emmanuel Macron à
laquelle je me suis retrouvé invité qui
était une vaste mascarade organisée par
sur la FNSE. Bon bref, on connaît la
chanson
et ton point de vue c'est là sur la
petits foot étaient pas bon. C'est ça ?
Ah non, j'en ai pas eu. J'en ai pas eu.
On a eu un café. Voilà. Mais parce qu'on
a dû changer de lieu parce que j'étais
là parce que mon grand ami Jean-Michel
Baileyet a dit qu'il était hors de
question parce qu'en fait tout le monde
était reçu à la dépêche. D'ailleurs toi
qui est quand même un média, tu noteras
avec amusement je pense que Macron euh
de à quelques mètres de Bailey a passé
la matinée dans les locaux du du groupe
La despêche. Euh
c'est bien son droit.
Et c'est bien son droit. Mais là où ça
devient quand même assez cocasse, c'est
que le l'un des grands sujets, c'était
donc la désinformation et la menace que
sont les réseaux sociaux et en parallèle
le péril des milliardaires de droite
stérin et boloré qui possèdent de la
presse. Je dis pas que c'est pas un
péril, je dis juste que tu es à 3 m d'un
milliardaire de gauche qui peut le
premier patron de presse régionale de
France, Franc Mac et tout ce que tu
veux. Et c'est
ça rien à voir, on s'en fout.
Bah on a rien à voir, on s'en fout. Non
non, c'est c'est pour expliquer quand
même le cadre. Si tu veux, ça c'était ce
qu'il y avait avant qu'on nous avant
qu'on nous reçoive et c'était une
parenthèse parce qu'au niveau de la
presse, c'est quand même voilà, c'est
quand même cocasse comment on nous prend
pour des cons sur tous les sujets si tu
veux. Mais euh donc après ben quand on
l'a vu,
tu as tu as lu de la désinformation
quelque part ?
Lu de la désinformation quelque part,
c'est-à-dire
est-ce que on a Est-ce qu'on t'a diffamé
? Est-ce qu'on toi
Ah oui, le le groupe la dépêche, on a un
procès d'ailleurs.
Bon, alors si c'est un procès en cours,
on va pas en parler. présemption
d'innocence pour tout le monde et ainsi
de suite.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Revenons à Macron, notre leader
charismatique
et il sent que ça couve, il fait que de
la communication creuse parce qu'il a
pas de solution.
Communication. Alors les solutions, il
les a mais il s'en fout. Il s'en fout
parce qu'en fait c'est la même mais
c'est la même chose pour tous les
problèmes de la société. On te dit non
mais on peut pas l'Europe a dit que mais
il est pas président de la France. On
n'est pas la deuxè puissance économique
d'Europe, la première puissance
militaire et j'en passe. On n pas la
bombe nucléaire. Enfin, qu'est-ce que
c'est cette histoire en fait ?
Au conseil de sécurité.
Non, mais si on dit aux Allemands, "Si
vous nous imposez ça et ça, on se
casse." Ils vont revoir leurs copies les
Allemands parce que si on sort de
l'Europe, ça va quand même être
sacrément compliqué pour eux, je pense
hein. Mais je peux me tromper
l'intrication des pays européens,
l'intrication le fait qu'on soit comme
au sein d'un grand cancer qui est en
train de métastaser un peu de partout
sur tous les domaines, on est intriqué.
Oui,
on peut peut-être plus sortir sans sans
faire d'énormes dégâts.
Bah je sais pas quand tu vois le Alors
bien sûr l'Angleterre a des gros
problèmes hein, mais quand tu vois au
final leur résultat, tu m'arrêtes si je
dis une connerie, mais quand tu vois
leur résultat, c'est
tu t'arrêtes
C'est pas la grande catastrophe
annoncée, hein.
C'est ils ont pas à rougir, hein. Alors
qu'ils étaient censés être condamnés à
anéantissement.
On pas vu. On n pas vu des averses de
crapau.
Non. Non. tempête de Non, même pas de
criqu des rivières en sang.
Non, on on les attend, on les attend.
Euh après, ils ont qu'ils ont des
problèmes. De toute façon, c'est pas le
sujet. Non, mais Macron nous a dit un
truc, tu vois, qui qui est formidable et
je te le dis, bah, je sais que tu
l'aimes. Donc donc voilà.
Attends, attends. Notre leader
charismatique, vas-y.
Euh, il nous a dit que de toute façon
donc que lui était pour le Mercossur
mais pas en l'état et qu'il voulait plus
de clause miroir. Donc ça,
effectivement, c'est le grand morceau de
violon. ou de flut de pan euh voilà
selon les les les goûts des gens. Euh
parce que les close mirror pour ceux qui
savent pas ce que c'est, c'est des
contrôles que de gentils messieurs vont
aller faire au Brésil dans des
multinationales qui payent des
milliards. Quand tu sais le niveau de
violence et de corruption qu'il y a
là-bas hein, ce sera euh du cash ou une
balle hein. Donc voilà, on sait très
bien comment ça se passera. C'est déjà
le cas avec les contrôles dans les pays
de l'Est. Mais vaste autre sujet.
C'est quoi tes sources ?
Ah je je
C'est quoi tes sources ? Ben je je non
alors j'ai pas de spicielle autant Plomo
et Plata en Amérique du Sud, je veux
bien y croire, autant les pays de l'Est,
c'est quand même des gens proches de
nous, de l'Europe.
Ah ouais, d'accord. Ouais. Ouais. Ouais.
Par exemple, en Ukraine, il y a aucune
corruption.
Non,
non. Et le dire, c'est complotiste.
Et et tu es complotiste en plus.
Non non parce que c'est mal. C'est mal.
Est-ce que tu t'es flagellé quand tu as
prononcé ce mot ? Il faut te flageler
quand tu tu prononces ce mot. Tu te'en
rends pas compte.
Attends, je le ferai pas devant la
caméra mais après j'irai me flageler.
C'est ton petit martinet. Oui, il est il
est derrière toi.
Comment ça s'appelle d'ailleurs le
martinet à clou là ? C'est pas le
martinet à clou tu sais les
ou non mais je vois très bien le l'outil
dont tu parles mais alors je connais pas
le le nom je joue pas avec ça donc je
revenons revenons à la corruption parce
que c'est clair qu'il y a de la
corruption mais même en France des
contrôles, tu peux avoir de la
corruption. Alors quand tu vas sur parce
que c'est aussi toujours pareil ce qu'il
faut que comprenne les gens c'est quand
je dis ça je vise pas les petits
producteurs polonais ou bulgares ou ce
que tu veux. C'est ce qu'on appelle, on
appelle même pas ça des bases, on
appelle ça des fermes. Les mecs se
déplacent en hélico, ils ont 5 10000
hectares. Quand tu pèses comme ça dans
un pays où le SMIC, bon en Pologne ça un
peu monté mais dans des pays comme la
Roumanie ou autreù tu as un SMIC à 300
balles ou 400 balles, mais qu'est-ce que
tu me racontes ? Le contrôleur il vient,
il prend son billet, il s'en va et puis
s'il veut pas son billet, il veut pas
prendre une tarte en fait parce qu'il
rigole pas là-bas. C'est la vie humaine
a pas tout à fait la même valeur que
chez nous.
Silis le petit fouet.
D'accord. Silis,
c'est bientôt Noël on t'en en verra.
La silis c'est c'est te sers avec la
silis, tu t'es trompé.
Revenons revenons à aux bases. Est-ce
que tu as vu les Polonais, les Roumains
gueuler contre les Ukrainiens et les
produits ukrainiens ?
Oui, tout à fait. Tout à fait. Ben faut
dire que la Pologne a complètement lâché
le soutien à l'Ukraine. Euh les
Hongrois, c'est pas un secret, mais tous
les paysans qui produisent des céréales
ou des œufs, du poulet sont fous en fait
de voir ça. Et puis en plus l'Ukraine,
enfin moi je n'ai rien contre les
Ukrainiens, c'est absolument horrible ce
qu' vivent, je suis d'accord là-dessus.
Mais enfin, à quel moment les Ukrainiens
dans l'histoire se sont sacrifiés pour
les Français ou on fait quoi que ce soit
? Enfin, c'est OK. Alors du coup, ils
sont blancs en fait. Ils sont blancs
donc on est frères en fait. C'est quoi ?
prends leur défense et je vais je vais
je vais prendre le le point de vue de
notre leader charismatique Emmanuel
Macron. C'est le premier bouclier de
l'Europe contre la menace russe
qui a pris 20 % du pays en 3 ans. Ouais,
c'est vrai qu'ils sont bientôt à Paris
du coup à ce rythme. Ouais, enfin on
sera peut-être mort quand il
on pourrait en discuter l'histoire de 20
% en 4 5 ans. Ils auraient pu faire une
guerre à l'américaine et raser
l'Ukraine.
Non mais tout mais tout à fait. Ben
quand ils ont joué envoyé un un Satan 2
sans charge. Ça c'était quand même
épique.
C'est pas un Satan 2. Satan
c'était un noisette
et c'était un noisette uniquement en
force inertielle. Euh euh
tu es bien meilleur que moi. Soit je
maîtrise pas mais enfin c'est le genre
de missile avec lequel tu fais de kief
un parking donc et même bien autour de
Kief. Donc
on verra.
Donc
pas rigoler, c'est euh
Oui, mais bon, enfin bref, c'est un rire
cynique. Il y a eu des millions de
morts. L'Europe essae désespérément de
gratter à la porte de la diplomatie
parce que comme ils sont pas la table,
ils sont forcément s
c'est un autre sujet. On va on va
traiter ça en 2026 et peut-être la
semaine prochaine, ça dépendra de notre
humeur et si on arrive à et je l'ai
plein d'avance parce qu'ils vont goûter
un plan Marchal SOS 2025, je leur laisse
bien volontiers mais c'est un autre
sujet.
sur le chat, ils sont en train de nous
envoyer les vidéos des inconnus avec le
martiouette. Les gars, il faut arrêter
de nous faire marer les gars. Revenons,
je prendrai les questions internet
après. Revenons à la mondialisation
agricole. Il y a pas des cadeaux entre
européens
avec les Roumains, les Polonais, les
Français, les Belges ?
Non,
mais déjà fédérer des gens à la hauteur
de d'une ville, c'est compliqué. à la
hauteur d'un département, c'est
compliqué, d'une région, d'un pays.
Alors, en plus, quand tu commences à à
rajouter des barrières culturelles,
linguistiques et autres, voilà. Mais
Macron nous a dit ça, nous a dit "Je
n'ai pas la minorité de blocage de toute
façon." Donc si l'Europe veut passer
même sans les
clauses miroir supplémentaires, ça
passera. Et il nous a dit "Si vous
voulez empêcher ça, c'est à vous de
convaincre les agriculteurs polonais et
polonais, pardon, italiens et espagnols
de mettre assez de pression sur leur
gouvernement pour qu'ils me rejoignent."
Euh mais c'est qui le président en fait
? Enfin, qu'est-ce qu'il nous raconte
lui en fait ? Mais c'est ce niveau de
déresponsabilisation et de et de renvoie
des responsabilité mais est fou en fait.
Quel chef d'état un tout petit peu stylé
aurait fait un truc comme ça en fait ?
Aucun. C'est c'est impensable. Voilà.
Donc après non ben il y a pas forcément
de de haine entre les autres entre les
paysans. Tu des fois il y a des petites
actions mais à fédérer c'est un délire.
Et puis on n'est pas, tu vois, par
exemple la CR, on est connu parce qu'en
fait on est
fédération
la la coordination,
on est on est on est en fait si tu veux
pour moi les syndicats et ça aussi ça
touche pas que l'agriculture crève d'un
truc crève de la soumission aux partis
politiques. Pour moi, les politiques et
je le dis tout le temps c'est les choses
des syndicats parce que nous on peut
briser la carrière d'un politique. On
n'est pas là pour faire de la politique,
on est là pour sauver une profession,
une interpression et cetera. Euh
culture, bordel. Oui oui. Non mais et si
tu veux le problème qu'on a c'est qu'en
gros euh on essaie de nous mettre dans
des cases à tout prix. Donc nous la CR
bah vu qu'on va au carton et qu'on est
les plus virulents euh on est l'extrême
droite. Euh la FD où il y a pas où il y
a quasiment enfin la FNSEA où il y a
quasiment pas un paysan qui vote Macron
mais où ils sont tenus par des
macronistes depuis que le mouvement
existe. Ça fait 80 ans qu'ils sont en
pouvoir donc voilà.
C'est pas 80 ans que notre leader
charismatique
Oui mais c'est en fait c'est le syndicat
du pouvoir donc en gros c'est le
syndicat des loges si tu préfères. C'est
le syndicat des lobbies, leur président
groupe avril, tout ça, tout ça, vaste
sujet. Quand tu parlais tout à l'heure
de paysans de bureau, Arnaud Rousseau en
est le plus bel exemple et je n'irai pas
plus loin afin d'éviter d'employer des
termes châtiers sur ta chaîne.
Oui. Alors euh qui aime bien châtie
bien, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
Et je te prends une question internet
euh qui me passe sous le martiouette.
Arrêter de faire des blagues. Euh
bonsoir. En tant que consommateur, que
me conseillez-vous de faire ? et après
on revient sur notre liber. Quel
esthmatique ?
Alors que que conseiller de faire ? Ben
selon où selon où tu vis, d'essayer au
maximum de privilégier les circuits
courts, d'essayer au maximum de
privilégier les paiements en espèce.
Non,
il faut payer ses impôts parce que ça
paye le salaire des infirmières, des
pompiers, de l'infrastructure, de la
retraite des boomers et de tout un tas
de choses.
Tu as presque l'air d'y croire quand tu
le dis. C'est c'est touchant. Il y a il
y a une émotion qui se dégage de toi.
C'est pas mal. Mais euh non mais puis
moi c'est même pas l'histoire de pas
payer ses impôts, c'est l'histoire
d'avoir une liberté en fait et puis
c'est l'histoire que toutes les
générations avant nous n'étaient pas
tenu sur ça et ont pu se construire
parce que nous aujourd'hui on le voit
euh sur alors je je j'ai plus la source
en tête mais si
tu as pas la source en tête
non mais c'est quelque chose que les
gens vont comprendre. Je ne vais pas
donner de chiffre du coup mais en gros
au bout d'un certain nombre d'années de
travail quotidien avec un salaire moyen
il y a 40 ans en arrière des profs
tu arrivais tu arrivais à multiplier par
deux ta richesse et sur une carrière
complète tu arrivais à le multiplier par
deux par trois voilà aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas parce qu'en fait tout
coûte extrêmement cher ponctionné de
partout tout est contrôlé et on te
réduit toujours tes libertés donc pour
répondre à cette personne ben moi les
meilleurs conseils que je pourrais lui
donner c'est ça c'est d'ess essayer de
privilégier les circuits courts. Alors,
les circuits courts, ça peut être des
réseaux d'AMAP, ça peut être des
magasins de producteurs parce qu'il y en
a de plus en plus, même dans les grandes
villes. Euh c'est sinon s'il a la chance
de vivre dans des zones un peu plus
reculées, d'acheter directement au
paysans, d'aller au marché bien entendu.
Euh et sinon ben même d'aller dans des
restaurants circuit courts, d'aller
voilà, il y a plein de belles
initiatives qui existent.
Travaille-toi avec des chefs étoilés qui
viennent chercher tes produits ?
Euh alors, j'ai travaillé avec un le
français le plus connu pour les
salaisons, le plus haut de gamme, voilà.
Mais en fait maintenant non parce que vu
que j'ai des petits volumes, je vends
tout en vente direct, je transforme tout
en fait. Donc j'ai pas de d'intérêt si
tu veux à vendre les bêtes entières. Moi
je transforme tout vraiment. Je fais la
naissance, l'engraissement, la
transformation et le séchage. Donc
vraiment c'est tout de
Revenons à notre leader charismatique et
solaire.
Vous tu dis tu dis les CR euh c'est les
plus violents ou c'est les plus les plus
turbulents ? les plus les plus
déterminés.
Vous avez été surveillé par la police ?
Vous êtes sur écoute ? Vous
Oui, je pense. Oui,
je pense très largement. Mais mais si tu
veux, comme je te dis, c'est toujours
cette politisation alors qu'en fait avec
la Confédération paysane, il y a
beaucoup de sujets où on n'est pas en
désaccord du tout. Ah, j'ai j'ai frotté.
T'inquiète, du moment qu'il change pas
de couleur, c'està dire que le son est
mort.
Euh donc, je disais avec avec la
Confédération de paysanne, on a beaucoup
de points d'accord en fait. Mais là où
il y a les problèmes, c'est quand c'est
justement trop politisé et que du coup
ben euh comment te dire eux c'est censé
être l'extrême gauche, nous l'extrême
droite et la FNSA, le syndicat du
pouvoir. Voilà. Bon ça c'est ça c'est un
gros problème surtout pour l'Union et
voilà c'est des problèmes comme je dis
qui tuent un peu un peu tout le monde
syndical. Je me suis perdu dans ce que
je voulais dire. C'était
c'était fait exprès et
je sais bien c'est mon petit mon petit
surnom
et ces syndiques
le pouvoir politique et la colère qui
couvre
h
Nous on va rajouter des facteurs pour
mettre les choses en perspective. L'euro
est une monnaie fantôme. H
la disponibilité, le prix énergétique de
la calorie ou de l'électron ne fait que
augmenter. H
ce qui va forcément
endurcir, forger et démultiplier
le feu qui couvre.
Tu as reçu ton petit fasicule de survie
en cas de guerre et ainsi de suite ? Je
l'ai pas eu.
Tu l'as pas téléchargé sur internet ?
Non, c'est vrai que j'ai pas fait mon
devoir de citoyen. Je te demande pardon.
Oui oui oui. Flagelle-toi un peu. Ce
pouvoir politique en contact avec les
syndicats, est-ce que les syndicats lui
font remonter la réalité de terrain ou
tu penses ? Ben,
je l'ai vu, je vais te dire ce que j'ai
vu. Alors certes, on peut me dire que
est-ce que tu penses que en fait ils ils
ne font remonter que du rondron
quotidien avec quelques petites tensions
ou c'est un réel reflet de la situation
?
Ben, je vais te donner ma vision des
choses qui n'engagent que moi, qui
engagé dans un syndicat, donc qui ne
suit peut-être pas impartial.
Euh comme je te l'ai dit, je pense que
la confit remonter beaucoup de vraies
choses mais manque d'énergie parce qu'en
fait les militants sont souvent assez
âgés et ils refuse les actions dures.
Donc du coup voilà. Et de l'autre côté,
ben la FNS là, je l'ai vu de mes yeux
avec Annie Jeunev et Macron le même jour
puisqu'on a fait 1h3 avec la ministre
puis 1 heure avec le président et la
ministre. Euh mais là c'est des
sourires, c'est il ils viennent ils
viennent représenter des mecs qui ont
envie de brûler nos dirigeants qui sont
à bout et
employer des mots qui sont pas
vulgaires, c'est très difficile mais ils
sont à genoux devant le pouvoir. Euh
quand tu dis ils ont envie de brûler,
non c'est imagé.
Non c'est pas imagé. Non je pense que
voilà, je pense que tu sais de toute
façon beaucoup de Français sont au-delà
de l'image et le monde agricole
crois-moi qu'il est à bout de chez About
vraiment. C'est pour ça que Macron a dit
queils vont finir par l'attraper euh ça
va finir vinaigre.
Macron a dit c'est quoi ?
Oui, il a dit qu'ils vont finir par le
buter ou un truc comme ça.
Ah bon ? Il a dit ça ? Je savais pas.
Bah écoute, espérons que ce soit Non, je
dit espérant que ce soit prophétique.
Non, qu'est-ce que je raconte ? Surtout
pas.
Non, la violence et la force des faibles
et commence où s'arrête les
connaissances. OK.
Après, il y a des stratégies
intéressantes autres que la violence.
Reviens reviens avec ton expérience avec
notre leader charismatique.
Oui.
En face de toi, tu me dis qu'il y a des
représentants syndicaux qui ne reflètent
pas la réalité de terrain.
Mais absolument pas. Mais quand il nous
a parlé du Mercossur, j'ai vu le
président parce que c'était les élus
régionaux d'Ocitanie qui était J'ai vu
le président région de de de la de la
FNSEA dire au président "Mais monsieur
le président" et je n'arrive plus à me
rappeler son mot précis. Donc je vais
dire les deux mots entre lesquels je
doute. Monsieur le président euh
qu'est-ce que je vais dire à ma base ?
et je sais plus s'il lui a dit ils vont
me dire que je suis un traître ou ils
vont me dire que je suis un lâche parce
que parce que Macron me disait qu'il
était donc pour le mercur et il lui a
demander s'il pouvait quand même
communiquer officiellement sur le fait
que il voulait pas signer le Mercosur
tant qu'il y avait pas les clauses
miroir supplémentaires. et quand il est
sorti, il a fait un discours à sa base
qui est filmé, que les gens peuvent
aller trouver sur Facebook sur voilà en
disant que voilà que le dialogue était
renoué, qui qu'il fallait faire
confiance que Macron était contre le
Mercosur,
il faut le voir pour le croire hein.
C'est et et j'ai vu aussi un président
de chambre d'agriculture venir, on est
dans un truc, tu vois, même si c'est une
pièce de théâtre organisée par le
pouvoir, on a l'occasion de faire
remonter les doléances de tous les gens
qui souffrent au quotidien et qu'on
côtoi. est tu as un mec président de
chambre d'agriculture qui s'en sort
extrêmement bien et tant mieux pour lui
ça c'est pas le problème qui se permet
de se plaindre devant eux de ses
problèmes persos parce qu'il veut créer
un énorme métaniseur et que les
habitants de son village sont pas
contents. Ça aussi il faut le voir pour
le croire si tu veux cette collusion
avec le pouvoir ce côté en fait les mecs
sont juste là pour être près du feu si
tu veux pour avoir les combines pour
avoir les financements quand il
enveloppe ton tu mets ton dossier en
premier. C'est ton interprétation.
C'est mon interprétation bien sûr. Donc
voilà. Donc pour te dire si tu veux pour
moi la FNSEA ne sert à rien parce
qu'elle est dans la complaisance
permanente parce qu'elle a appelé à
voter Macron deux fois. Ils ont été à
être cocus jusqu'à appeler à soutenir
Bairou. Enfin tu vois, c'est des trucs
impensables en fait quand tu vois l'état
du monde agricole et que tu continues
sur cette ligou
il a été au commissaire au plan.
Oui. Au plan de quoi ? On sait pas.
Le plan sur la comète.
Ouais. De plan sur la comète. Mais si tu
veux, tu vois, pour parler des problèmes
dans l'agriculture,
il a fait il a fait quelques papiers, il
était bénévole en plus.
Ouais, bénévole. Ouais, beau bénévolat
là. H Mais euh
pourquoi les agriculteurs ils bypassent
pas les syndicats maintenant qu'il y a
internet, les réseaux sociaux ?
Mais parce que tout le monde a peur.
Tout le monde a peur de de d'aller au
carton en premier. En fait, moi déjà
d'être là et de dire ce que je dis, tout
le monde me dit que je suis fou. Les
gens me disent "J'ai beaucoup de soutien
parce que les gens se retrouvent
là-dedans." Mais on me dit en permanence
d'arrêter que je vais avoir des
problèmes. avec bienveillance des amis,
des proches, des enfants,
j'ai un fils
et au contraire pour moi c'est enfin non
pas que j'ai envie qu'il grandisse en
son père mais c'est une motivation parce
que comme je te l'ai dit pour moi
vraiment l'heure est extrêmement grave
par rapport à la notion de souveraineté
alimentaire parce que si on la perd on
retrouvera jamais nos libertés et si je
dois avoir des problèmes XXL pour que
mon fils soit pas un [__] d'esclave
ainsi soit-il. Donc au contraire, c'est
plus une motivation qu'autre chose, tu
vois. Mais
non, c'est comment te dire ? C'est c'est
compliqué de
c'est c'est compliqué quand tu n'es
rien, quand tu es tout seul et que tu es
isolé, reculé à la campagne. Qu'est-ce
que tu veux aller faire contre l'État ?
À part aller faire une dinguerie avec un
fusil ? Qu'est-ce que tu veux aller
faire contre l'État ?
D'ingie avec un cochon.
Oui, mais là, il y a pas de violence.
Tu lui as rendu la lali avant ou bien ?
Je lui ai rendu quoi ?
Les honneurs.
Je parle du cochon. Ou
ou non ? Mais il était mort empoisonné.
Donc voilà. Mais euh bref,
c'est qu'est-ce que tu vas faire tout
seul ? C'est pour ça qu'il y a des
syndicats. Mais quand je ma question
c'est c'est en fait l'autoorganisation
grâce aux réseaux sociaux, à internet,
aux mailing list, moi les agriculteurs
qui nous font monter des infos, les mecs
ils sont ultra connectés. Oui, mais il
faut arriver à peser si en fait si tu
veux si tu n'as pas c'est malheureux.
Moi si j'ai accepté de voir Emmanuel
Macron, c'est pas parce que j'étais une
groupie mais c'est parce que tu as une
occasion dans ta vie de faire remonter
au leader suprême des doléances. Si tu
pisses dans un violon, tu pisses dans un
violon. Mais au moins tu as essayé pour
tous les mecs qui souffrent au
quotidien. En fait, tu te dois d'y aller
en fait. Et quel que soit le mouvement
de résistance que tu veux mener, euh OK,
la violence c'est pas bien, mais tu as
deux options, hein. Soit tu montes un
groupe pour faire un coup d'état, euh
soit il faut être capable d'une
organisation et d'une force de frappe
suffisante pour créer un rapport de
force avec l'État pour que l'État
t'écoute. Et moi ce à quoi je pousse et
que je demande avec insistance, mais je
suis pas le seul parce que tout le monde
en a envie, j'ai l'impression, à notre
nouveau président à la CR, c'est qu'on
lance un blocage national mais un vrai
et d'appeler derrière toute la
population non agricole à nous suivre.
Euh voilà, j'ai un petit projet à ce
niveau-là, mais je suis en discussion
avec mes avocats pour éviter d'aller en
prison où il y aurait pas de casse, mais
où on arrête le pays et où les hommes,
les femmes, les retraités, les tout le
monde peut participer en quelques
minutes par jour sans dépenser d'argent.
Et ça, ce serait terrible pour l'État.
Ah bah oui, mais ça va être terrible
aussi pour le salaire des profs, ça va
être terrible sur la note des marchés.
On a 3500 milliards de dettes, on joue
avec l'argent du monopolie. Tu as connu
le Covid, tu as connu le reste. Euh ça
changera rien
3300. Non
ouais à vérifier.
On est plus à 200 milliard vérifier.
Mais j'aimerais bien avoir le chiffre si
notre facter peut l'avoir. Mais mais euh
je je crois que
est-ce que vous avez pensé à d'autres
stratégies de type guerre de l'image, la
prise de contrôle des vecteurs
d'information ?
Mais mais il s'en fout. Enfin tu vois
bien s
adressé directement à la population.
Non mais quand tu vois le Oui mais la
population elle est pas dupe. La
population elle le est à Macron. Mais
lui, enfin moi pour l'avoir rencontré,
moi ce type quand j'ai dit que j'avais
l'impression d'avoir vu le diable, je le
pense vraiment. Moi il m'a fallu de
jours pour me remettre de cette
rencontre.
Oui, mais j'ai dit l'impression. Je je
Tu crois en Dieu ?
Oui.
Quel Dieu ? Moi, je suis catholique
traditionnaliste. Ça aussi ça va être la
légende. Oui.
En latin ?
Oui.
Non.
Si tous les dimanches.
Vas-y. Tu parles latin ?
Tu parles latin ? J'ai fait du latin au
collège, mais je parle pas latin.
En fait, tu écoutes de la musique à la à
l'église ? En fait, il y a un truc à
l'église qui s'appelle le micel. Voilà.
Donc en fait,
ça c'est ça. Tu as la messe que du
qui est bien souvent chanté en plus que
donc tu as la moitié de la page en latin
et là à côté tu as la traduction en
français. Donc ça va, ça va.
Revenons revenons à Macron.
Ouais.
Que tu penses
être le visage
du démon. H
pourquoi tu me dis le visage de démon ?
Il paraît dire qu'il est hyper car. Nous
on l'a jamais rencontré
charismatique
avec un regard bleu ciel magnifique un
sexe à pile extraordinaire.
Non, j'irai pas jusque là mais
non il a une mais de toute façon si tu
veux quand je vois moi j'ai dit quand
j'ai dit aux gens qu'il m'avait
impressionné c'était pas dans un sens
positif si tu veux mais il y a des gens
qui disent moi il m'impressionneraiit
jamais machin mais je suis pas un père
je suis passionné de géopolitique depuis
que je suis gamin euh je suis pas son
ami d'ailleurs. Je suis pas un héros. Il
y a des gens qui ont fait plus que moi,
un certain Damien Tarel, mais moi je lui
ai quand même dit en fait que c'était un
traître, tu vois, parce que je le pense.
Euh, comment te dire ?
Un traître par forfaiture ou un traître
par renoncement ?
Ah, je n'ai pas développé à ce point,
mais pour moi, un traître à la nation en
fait, mais grâce à son ami Nicolas,
c'est plus un problème. Mais ce que les
gens doivent comprendre, c'est qu'unol
Nicolas S. Euh un écrivain célèbre qui a
sorti le journal d'un prisonnier
récemment que je t'invite à acheter. À
mon avis, c'est de la de la bonne
lecture.
Bon ben je te l'offrirai pour Noël. Tu
m'envoies de quoi me flageller. Je
t'enverrai le le journal du prisonnier.
Euh mais euh non, comment dire ? C'est
c'est
pénitence.
Sacrée pénitence.
C'est pas le câu.
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Mais sacrée
pénitence là. Mais bon, pourquoi pas ?
Euh, enfin non, même pas. Mais bon,
bref. Euh, tu peux tu peux sortir
Macron
euh si tu si tu veux, tu arrives en
sachant qui il est, tu arrives en
vraiment avec une certaine animosité
mais si c'est le petit protégé de M et
d'Atalie, c'est pas pour rien si tu
veux. Eux c'est peut-être
c'est pas un protégé, c'est un poulin.
Oui, mais enfin leur poulin leur
protéger, ce que tu veux. Ce que je veux
dire, c'est que ces mecs-là sont
peut-être et j'assume, c'est mes mots
des pourritures mais ils sont pas
idiots. Pardon, excuse-moi Talie. Non,
c'est un mec bien.
Je t'ai dit prendre de la hauteur.
Oui,
de la de la pr. Mais là pour dire ça,
faut être très très haut parce que sinon
le vocabulaire est plus châtié. Mais
bon, bref euh
c'est pas bien de faire ça. C'est même
si c'est si
si c'était vrai,
c'est pas ça. C'est il faut si tu penses
que c'est tes ennemis, il faut toujours
respecter l'ennemi.
Ah mais justement ce que je dis
derrière, c'est qu'ils sont
intelligents. Ils sont dénués d'humanité
mais ils sont intelligents. Et avec lui,
c'est ça que j'ai ressenti.
Retire tes mots, il faut pas faire ça.
Mais c'est des mots que je pense. Je
peut-être tort. Je suis peut-être con de
le dire, pourquoi pas ? Mais c'est ce
que je pense. Donc moi, je je maintiens
ce que je pense. J'essayé de pas tomber
dans l'injure grave, mais c'est ce que
je pense.
C'est rien d'injurer d'injurier.
Non, mais il faut appeler un chat un
chat. Et j'ai aucun terme plus poli que
ça pour les désigner. Mais peu importe.
Ce que j'ai ressenti avec Macron si tu
veux, c'est que il est amoureux de son
reflet. Il est amoureux de lui-même plus
que de tout. Et il est complètement
dépourvu d'empathie et d'humanité en
fait vraiment. Euh euh tous autant qu'on
est dans la pièce avec nos enfants, si
on devait crever, tant que ça pose pas
problème à ses intérêts ou à son image,
il n'en a absolument rien à faire. Et
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui qui qui
dégage à un point que tu n'imagines pas.
Et il est doué effectivement d'un
charisme incroyable. Incroyable. Quand
il te parle, il vend il vendrait du
sable à des bédoins sans problème. Il
est très très fort à ce niveau-là.
Après, si tu veux, il y a euh si tu es
un si tu es pas complètement idiot, tu
vois bien qu'il te bourre le mou. Mais
le en même temps macronien quand tu l'as
en face, c'est très fort. Il t'explique
à la fois que tu as tout compris, que tu
es une chèvre si tu veux. Il t'explique
à la fois qu'il est qu'il est pour le
mercur mais en même temps euh qu'il est
contre si tu veux. Et il arrive à
switcher comme ça en permanence. C'est
c'est vraiment particulier comme
rencontre. Moi vraiment, il m'a fallu de
jours pour digérer ça et et ça m'a
paniqué si tu veux sur le point auquel à
mon sens on est dans la merde parce que
parce que ça dépasse. J'étais conscient,
je dis je suis passionné de de diverses
émissions que ce soit mon pote Tabibian,
que ce soit ce que tu fais soit sur la
géopolitique, sur la politique, sur
Donc, j'étais conscient des choses. Mais
quand tu vois l'artiste qu'on a au
manette en face
euh Ouais, mais je te jure que ça fait
peur.
Nous, on le voit pas. On voit surtout le
l'endettement de la France et la balance
commerciale et ça nous fait très peur. H
euh je vais te poser une question puis
je vais en profiter pour avoir le regard
sur les questions internet en même
temps. Euh parle-moi de ta passion
avec tes mots et donne-moi ton plus beau
souvenir
sur ton exploitation.
Mon plus beau souvenir ?
Ben mon
plus beau souvenir, c'est la première
portée que j'ai eu. Tu vois les premiers
les premiers porcela qui sont nés quand
j'ai démarré avec des jeunes
reproducteur. Ça c'était fabuleux.
Euh et les premières productions les
premières productions aboutis quand tu
goûtes et que ça déchire. Euh là c'est
vraiment euh voilà parce que dans ma
petite histoire personnelle si tu veux
vu que je me suis retrouvé très
médiatisé quand mes premiers quand mes
premiers produits sont sortis même si
j'avais une expérience que je
connaissais que j'étais sûr de ma viande
que tu as un peu peur tu sais un peu le
je crois ça s'appelle le syndrome de
l'imposteur tu vois de te dire [__]
mais si je me loupe je vais être la plus
grosse frotte de France et quand tu
goûtes et que ça déchire tu bon voilà
mais ma passion mais je te dis c'est
quelque chose que qui se déc décrit pas,
ça se vit. C'est c'est un amour du
vivant. C'est un amour en fait, c'est de
la liberté parce que quand tu es paysan,
tu as beaucoup de contraintes de tout ce
qu'on veut mais c'est une vie assez
libre parce qu'en fait tu es ton propre
patron, tu es dans la nature, tu te
fixes tes objectifs, tu je sais pas
comment expliquer, je sais je je saurais
pas le décrire.
Pression énorme.
Ouais, c'est une pression énorme mais en
même temps c'est un bonheur
indescriptible. Oui, j'ai dit en même
temps. Je sais mais il a pas déposé les
mots, j'y peux rien.
Question internet. Quelle est l'action à
l'échelle populaire ? Je je vais mettre
des des guillemets populaires. Donc,
quelle est l'action à l'échelle
populaire la plus efficace pour faire
changer les choses, améliorer la qualité
nutritionnelle des aliments de base et
soutenir l'agriculture ? En quelques
mots, tu fini,
ça rejoint un peu la question qu'il y
avait tout à l'heure. Euh ben en fait,
je dirais du contrôle aux frontières. En
fait, si tu veux améliorer la qualité
des aliments, c'est du contrôle aux
frontières pour que on tout ce qui
rentre chez nous soit produit avec les
mêmes normes qu'on veut chez nous. Et à
partir de là, tu peux te permettre
d'avoir une agriculture encore plus
verte, encore plus saine, de tirer vers
le haut en fait en nivelant vers le haut
au lieu de niveler vers le bas tout
simplement. Euh voilà, je sais pas si
j'ai répondu mais je pense que à peu
près
question internet. Bonsoir. Quelles sont
les propositions pour faciliter
l'installation et le maintien des
exploitations non industrielles au
niveau national ?
en fait du prix et quand je dis ça, ça
veut pas dire que ce soit plus cher pour
le consommateur mais du prix parce qu'en
fait si tu n'as pas de prix c'est pour
ça que tu installes pas ton fils parce
que tu vas pas l'installer dans un truc
qui va où il va devoir s'endetter pour
te racheter la ferme et s'endetter pour
avoir de nouveaux moyens d'équipement et
je peux vous excusez-moi vous êtes
fessine ça m'a perdu
mais c'est pas ça on a une bromance avec
le cadreur
D'accord. Oui, je respecte cela.
Continue. Désolé de t'avoir coupé
mais euh mais du coup oui euh
le prix donc ben déjà qui est du prix
après de voir pour faciliter pour
simplifier les les les transmissions euh
et puis et puis de ben en fait si tu
veux une vraie enfin simplification
administrative et et normative moins de
concurrence des loyal. En fait, si on
règle les problèmes de rentabilité du
monde agricole, on facilitera
l'installation. Après, il y a plein de
process à mettre en place euh mais là,
on rentre dans des trucs, je sais pas
comment t'expliqu, on pourra en parler
des heures. Mais on a un problème en
France, c'est que vu qu'on a un problème
d'installation et de renouveau, si tu
veux, les meilleures terres agricoles
sont rachetées par des consortiums bien
souvent étrangers. À l'exemple, on a
parlé de Black Rock, mais ça peut être
chinois, ça peut être peu importe. Et
les terres de coto, les pentes, les
trucs comme ça sont délaissés. Et donc
ça ça va devenir des friches mais là il
y a la place d'installer des gens en
élevage, en maréchage, en tout ce qu'on
veut. Donc
à voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de ces
sols sans tomber non plus dans le
communisme le plus total si tu veux.
Mais
tu parlais de Jack Atal tout à l'heure.
Alors je vais te livrer une petite
anecdote personnelle. Nous on s'est déjà
quand on était jeune un peu plus jeune
on s'est déjà pris le nez avec Jack
Atal. Je sais pas s'il s'en rappellera,
il connaît notre mentor Marc Hulman et
Marc Hullman nous avait fait venir
Jacques et on l'avait chauffé sur des
sujet géopolitique. Bon, il s'était il
était un peu professoral avec nous. Bon,
tu as pas essayé de faire un hack ? Tu
appelles Jacques, tu lui dis "Jacques
viens on discute autour d'un verre de
pinard, même s'il boit pas de pinard et
même s'il a un régime strict." Et tu tu
lui tu lui parles et tu dis "Comble le
fossé intergénérationnel,
aide-nous, on va t'aider, tu vas nous
aider et on va essayer de sauver le
pays." Est-ce que tu as essayé de te
réconcilier
avec les gens qui sont durs ou que tu
penses dur dans leur gestion de la
politique française ? Est-ce que tu
peux, tu me dis que tu es câau le
pardon. Est-ce que tendre la main, tu
connais ça ? Est-ce que tu t'es dit
peut-être
j'ai été turbulent quand j'étais jeune,
je vais essayer de le contacter le PP
parce que PP est quand même gentil, ça
reste un pépé
et tu lui dis viens dans mon
exploitation,
il faut il faut que tu nous aides parce
que tu es au crépuscule de ta vie
Jacques. Les jeunes pensent peut-être
que ça a mal été géré.
Tu dois t'en rendre compte aussi parce
que la démographie se casse la gueule,
parce que les gamins vont mal, parce que
les étudiants vont mal.
Mettons-nous autour de la table et
sauvons ce qu'il y a à sauver. Je vais
utiliser tes 160 de cuits, tu vas
utiliser mes 160 de cuit. On va Est-ce
que tu Et même alors peut-être Macron
tuas abandonné mais on peut comprendre
pourquoi. Est-ce que tu as essayé
le pardon
à mes yeux ? De toute façon,
j'ai vécu des choses par certaines
personnes que je peut-être même dans
cette vie que je n'aurais pas la force
de pardonner, tu vois. Mais ça après, il
s'arrange avec le patron.
Attention, mais bien sûr, mais le fait
d'être catholique, ça veut pas dire que
je vaux mieux que quelqu'un qui n'est
pas catholique.
Il on juge pas les gens valent pas
mieux, les croyants valent pas mieux que
les non croyants. C'est pas c'est pas ça
mon raisonnement. Je pense que c'est
fondamental à plein de niveaux, mais en
fait c'est que ça te donne des des pas
des valeurs, des principes, c'est quand
même plus solide. Des principes et des
lignes directrices pour essayer de bien
te comporter dans ta vie. Maintenant le
pardon euh il faut qu'il y ait une
repentance.
Mais tu trouves pas qu'il fait sa
repentance en ce moment ? Mais
il fait des vidéos sur internet avec un
petit micro qui fonctionne pas très mal.
Pardon, ma ma voix est morte. Euh la
dernière vidéo que j'ai vu de lui,
c'était à l'époque du Covid où il
parlait mal à une petite jeune parce
qu'elle avait son masque mal mis alors
qu'il lui parlait qu'il avait pas de
masque. Donc ce mec vraiment la
repentance si tu veux euh
je pense qu'à part Dieu, personne pourra
le pardonner à lui.
Si je t'organise.
Ah bah si tu m'organises, moi je je
prends le
tu payes ton apéro.
Ah mais tous les jours, je te ramène
encore trois fois plus de charcuterie.
Ah ouais. Euh euh
si moi je fais le médiateur entre tout
ce petit monde, c'est-à-dire pour éviter
qu'on termine qu'on termine tous,
tu serais notre Messi.
Non.
Si, parce que ces gens-là, le problème
c'est qu'il y a pas de médiation. Moi je
ne vois pas de médiation possible. En
fait, de toute façon, quand tu te
heurtes à des gens très puissants ou à
l'état français, tu te rends compte que
tout n'est que rapport de force. C'est
pas joli, c'est pas beau, c'est pas
gentil, mais tout n'est que rapport de
force. Si tu ne pèes rien, tu es de la
merde et on t'écoute pas.
Tu es en train de parler comme le
général Mandon.
[__] c'est infernal. Euh,
tu si si tu veux vraiment le rapport de
force, tout n'est régi que par ça. Et et
le gouvernement a peur parce que la
France c'est puissant, l'Europe c'est
puissant mais c'est des géants au pied
d'argile et ils ont vraiment peur de ce
qu'on peut faire. Moi ce que je ce dont
je rêve c'est d'arriver à arrêter ce
pays. Et je dis si ça doit coûter des
sous, si ça doit mais la préoccupation
doit pas être là. Si on perd la
souveraineté alimentaire, on perd toute
option de garder un contrôle sur ce
pays, de contrôler notre destin et de
pouvoir choisir ce qu'on veut pour
demain en fait, quel que soit le bord
politique. Donc si les gens ils en
prennent pas conscience et ben on va
tous devenir des immenses esclaves. On
va continuer à nivel par le bas
puissance 10. En fait, le premier
maillon, ça je le répète tout le temps,
mais le premier maillon pour construire
une société, que tu prennes les nazis ou
les communistes, c'est pareil, c'est la
bouffe.
Non, tu prends pas les nazis.
Oui, mais tu m'as compris. C'est
tu peux prendre les communistes, mais
les nazis, tu les laisses dans leur leur
ton.
Non, non, mais on prend Moi, je te dis,
c'est quel que soit le système social
que tu veux choisir, euh le modèle, le
premier maillon c'est la bouffe, le
deuxième, c'est la sécurité, le troisème
c'est la santé et après c'est
l'éducation. Bon, quand ils auront pété
euh le le l'alimentation et que donc on
sera verrouillé et que ce sera très
compliqué de se rebeller, l'étape
d'après, c'est d'empêcher des
révolutions, des révoltes, des donc
c'est quoi ? c'est détruire la police en
créant en faisant la même chose que les
Américains, un FBI européen si tu veux,
en créant une police européenne qui va
avoir des prérogative et puis après elle
récupérera telle affaire qui lui donnera
des nouvelles prérogatives comme avec le
FBI jusqu'à ce qu'il puisse toucher à
tout, qu'il puisse après cracher sur les
flics français, ne pas les écouter
qu'ils soient leur supérieur en fait. Et
du coup quand tu auras des problèmes,
ben si on t'envoie des CRS ukrainiens au
polonais en face, tu vas pas blaguer
longtemps. Donc euh
moi j'aime bien les CRS belges,
je ne les connais pas.
Ils sont très gentils. Euh revenons,
revenons à l'agriculture. Vous les
agriculteurs, vous êtes connectés avec
vos copains de la des marins pêcheurs ?
Oui, il y a des contacts. Oui, oui, oui,
oui.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit du côté des marins
pêcheurs ?
Ben, je sais pas. Quand je te dis qu'ils
ont envie de cramer, tu me dis qu'il
faut pas le dire. Donc, mais les marins
pêcheurs, ils sont ils sont colères.
Ils sont grosse colère.
Ils sont grosse colère les marins
pêcheurs. Oui. Oui. En même temps, c'est
tellement affreux aussi ce qu'ils vivent
que c'est entre les le fait de ne plus
pouvoir pêcher les coûts de l'énergie,
le fait qu'on les étrange sur les prix,
tout en fait. Et d'ailleurs, il y avait
eu une petite action à Paris où les
marins pêcheurs s'étaient joints à la à
la CR et où en fait il vendaient aux
gens les produits au prix où les
grossistes leur achètent pour que les
gens voient en fait. Ah merde ! Mais en
fait les coquilles saint-jacques, le
pêcheur on lui achète à que dalle en
fait. C'est comment ça se fait ? Voilà.
Donc non mais c'est de toute façon cette
colère, elle est au-delà du monde
agricole. Mais
toi, tu
as pas une profession qui est pas à bout
dans ce pays.
Toi, tu es vilain. En fait, tu es tu es
pour l'interdiction des petites
toilettes sur les bateaux des
austréciculteurs. Je le savais avant de
t'inviter qu'il fallait pas t'inviter,
que tu étais contre ce petit confort.
Question internet. Vous rappelez souvent
que la coordination rurale se veut un
syndicat professionnel à politique qui
ne donne pas de consigne de vote et
discute avec tous les partis pour
défendre les agriculteurs.
Comment justifiez-vous alors de vous
afficher avec le RN ou Éric Zemour dans
les votes et les programme ne règlant
pas concrètement les problèmes de prix,
d'endettement, de survie des petites
fermes sans que cela remette en cause
cette prétention à l'apolitisme.
Alors, c'est une très bonne question et
non mais c'est vrai et à laquelle je
vais répondre en toute franchise.
Tu crois que tu es venu pour pousser un
cad ou quoi ?
Je t'ai dis je t'ai dit
c'est pas possible de t'énerver
si mais après quand je m'énerve
justement je bref on parle plus après
euh
comment dire euh non mais la question en
plus est vachement importante. C'est
bien qu'elle soit posée. Euh moi
effectivement j'ai reçu Éric Zemour sur
ma ferme. Ouais. Et franchement, j'en
suis fier parce que les discussions ont
été étaient hyper intéressantes
parce que quand tu as des politiques de
premier plan avec qui tu peux parler en
off pendant des heures, c'est
franchement passionnant quel que soit le
bord. Mais moi en fait, j'ai contacté
aussi Fabien Rousell,
comment il s'appelle ? Ruffin. J'ai
invité tout le monde, j'ai invité les
socialistes. J'ai Mais ils ont piscine
en fait. Et avec Ruffin et Roussell, on
a vachement bien discuté avec leur leur
dircab là et enfin leur dircab je sais
pas comment on appelle ça leur leur leur
bras droit quoi et euh et ils étaient
chauds puis il y a eu des pression donc
ils sont pas venus mais moi en fait Éric
Zemour c'est
tu as pas parlé de Mélenchon Mélenchon
il serait déplacé
alors Mélenchon je pense qu'à mettre en
face des paysans c'est compliqué
pourtant son programme agricole son
programme agricole était pas si mauvais
que ça franchement il faut lui Non mais
je lui reconnais sans problème Mais non
parce qu'il y a une vraie détestation
parce qu'en fait il à mes yeux en tout
cas il déteste son pays
et donc si tu veux les paysans ils sont
enracinés. Donc quand tu craches sur la
France, sur le drapeau français sur le
peuple français sur
Il jamais craché sur le drapeau
français.
Tu n'y crois même pas
mais c'est passé. Je l'ai pas vu.
Oui benah enfin tu vois bien tu vois
bien ce que cautionne la France
insoumise si tu veux.
On connait les paroles de la
marseillaise
ouais ben c'est bien.
Question internet.
Mais du coup attends j'ai pas pu
répondre à la question. Excuse-moi mais
parce qu'elle est importante. Il y a un
leader de chez nous qui a appelé une
fois à soutenir Bardella. Ça c'est vrai.
Bon de la vie de tout le monde à la CR,
c'était une connerie parce que c'est pas
notre rôle de faire ça. Après moi ce que
je veux dire pour Zemour, c'est que
c'est lui qui m'a contacté et j'ai
accepté s'il acceptait lui de faire face
à tous les paysans du département qu'il
voulait pour échanger à bâton rompu sans
préparation sur les problèmes du monde
agricole. et il a relevé le défi. Ça
s'est très bien passé et je voulais
faire ça avec tous les partis
politiques. Sauf que vu que je suis ami
avec Papacito et que je le renieri
jamais jusqu'à ce que Moren suive, une
certaine extrême gauche à matrice de
censure a décidé que j'étais un Asie et
que du coup il fallait pas parler avec
moi. Mais moi, justement, je parle avec
tout le monde, je suis à politique et je
reconnais qu'il y a un paquet de mecs à
gauche qui peuvent être intéressants.
Bien sûr, la droite n'a pas toute la
lumière et de la même manière qu'il y a
des choses très intéressantes à droite.
Et je vois pas en fait, moi comme tu as
dit, je suis câau, le Messi, j'en
connais qu'un donc j'en vois pas en
politique. Mais si demain il y avait un
mec qui arrive avec un vrai programme
pour sauver l'agriculture française
vraiment pertinent et accessoirement une
sortie de l'Union européenne, je suis
prêt à lui faire sa promo gratuitement à
faire, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Moi, mon but, c'est l'intérêt commun en
fait.
Tu crois donc à un ami imaginaire ?
Euh, écoute, on peut commencer à parler
théologie si tu veux, mais non, moi pour
moi c'est pas un ami imaginaire. Non.
Question internet. Pourquoi Pierre-
Guillaume a vu son combat et sa
revendication àolitique, a-t-il choisi
la coordination rurale et pas la
Confédération paysane ? J'ai été des
années à la Confédération paysane. J'ai
même dirigé pendant 3 ans la
Confédération paysane de mon
département. Et en fait, le national de
la Confédération paysane euh m'a demandé
de quitter mon a demandé que je quitte
mon poste quand j'ai été médiatisé avec
Papacito en fait. parce que euh et c'est
ce que je reproche à la Confédération
paysane, c'est qu'au niveau national en
fait, ils sont dirigés vraiment
littéralement par leurs salariés qui
sont plus des paysans et euh que ça
devient politique au point que ça
devient un parti politique. Et ça c'est
très très dommageable parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de bonnes idées mais ça c'est
très dommageable. Et voilà. Et si je
suis à la CR, c'est parce que ben en
fait c'est les seuls qui bougent. quand
j'étais à la conf, si je entre
guillemets dirigeais le département,
pareil hein, j'ai jamais pris un j'ai
jamais eu 1 € pour ça. Mais si je
faisais ça euh c'est parce que ça défend
ce que j'aime à la confe c'est qu'il
défendent les petites fermes. Ça, on
peut pas le enlever, c'est hyper
important. Mais la CR aussi. Et en fait,
dans toutes les commissions, j'étais
d'accord avec les mecs de la CR à chaque
fois. Donc quand on m'a on m'a dit que
j'étais euh trop gênant pour être
porte-parole mais euh enfin diriger le
département quoi, mais euh qu'il fallait
que je pouvais continuer à aller
bénévolement dans toutes les
commissions, euh j'ai dit "Si au revoir
et 1 an après, j'ai rejoint la CR et si
je voulais, je ne seraiis jamais allé à
la FNSEA." Et la CR en fait, moi j'aime
bien aller au carton et la CR en fait,
il y a beaucoup de gars comme ça et ça
ça me plaît quoi, c'est tout.
C'est toi qui est responsable des
panneaux retournés dans les villages ?
Non, ça c'est une idée de la FNSE au
départ. Nous ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
les inverse entre les villes mais bon
sauf c'est une connerie. Nous c'est plus
que tous les radars sont jeunes en fait.
Nous chez nous les radars ils flashent
pas beaucoup.
Non mais tu détruis
de l'investissement public.
Si c'est bon on fera une autre émission
tous les deux où je te taperai un peu
plus dessus. Je te ferai absoudre tes
péchés. Allons-y
mon frère.
Euh question internet et je demande à la
communauté de faire monter les
meilleures questions en mettant des
petits pouces ou des petits cœurs pour
qu'on puisse les repérer plus
facilement. Question internet. Est-ce
que est-ce qu'à vouloir faire une
alimentation toujours plus vertueuse, on
a oublié de faire de l'alimentation pour
les classes populaires ? Est-ce que
l'agriculture française a pour avenir de
nourrir uniquement les bobos citadins ?
Non. Non. Et tu peux arriver à manger
bien pour beaucoup moins cher que tu le
crois. Tout dépend déjà où et comment tu
te fournis. Après, je répète pour les
gens qui vivent à Lyon, à Paris, à
Marseille, je peux entendre que ce soit
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que c'est
très chronophage. Mais si tu fais ton
marché dans des villes de moindre
importance que donc les plus grosses
villes françaises et que tu vas
directement au producteur, je t'assure
que c'est beaucoup moins cher qu'au
supermarché. Donc
touche le Omar à Doll de Bretagne,
un prix imbattable en pleiné.
au bord de la mer si tu vas à la crier
ton poisson c'est un délire tu as du
super poisson pour pour trois fois rien
et voilà donc même si trois fois rien ça
peut être une somme pour les gens c'est
pas la question mais je veux dire non le
problème là-dessus comme on l'a dit
c'est comment c'est géré au niveau de la
grande distribution euh les contrôles
aux frontières en fait il faut qu'on
arrive à standardiser ce qu'on veut
manger en France il faut qu'on ait le
contrôle sur ce qui rentre en France
pour que les Français décident ce qu'ils
veulent manger c'est tout et après on
peut mettre en place des politiques
publiques et autres pour arriver à ce
que tout se passe bien au niveau des
prix et à ce que les choses soient
faites beaucoup mieux. Mais quand ceux
qui te vendent la bouffe, c'est les plus
gros des requins euh et que les paysans
se font saigner et que les les
consommateurs se font saigner, c'est
qu'il y a un problème en fait. C'est
c'est tout. Il faut que les gens se
rendent vraiment compte du delta qui est
entre le prix auquel on achète la
production au paysan et le prix où il la
retrouve en grande surface.
Ils ont des charges aussi. Oui.
Euh tiens, en t'écoutant, tu m'as donné
une idée brillante ou du moins je vais
la transmettre aux agriculteurs.
Apprenez à la population à bien choisir
les produits de qualité. Tu on parlait
du moi, je parlais en faisant une
boutade qui ne fonctionnait pas, des
poissons des homars que tu achètes
vraiment pas cher direct producteur.
Demander au producteur comment
reconnaître un beau produit. Par
exemple, Omar, il faut qu'il ait les les
antennes longues parce que comme ça, il
s'est pas castagné, il est pas resté
avec ses copains se castagnés dans le
dans le vivier très longtemps. Ou le
poisson, il faut qu'il soit arrête comme
un coup de tri avec l'œil brillant et la
la les branchis bien rouges.
Apprenez au consommateur à reconnaître
la vraie bouffe.
Oui. Le problème aussi c'est que le
consommateur, je peux comprendre hein,
que il puisse y avoir un questionnement
ou même une renqueur selon comment on
comprend ce qui se passe contre les
paysans. Mais il faut comprendre que le
problème c'est aussi le consommateur
parce que les gens il faut arrêter aussi
de se déresponsabiliser. On jette
pratiquement 50 % de ce qui est produit
dans ce pays.
On jette, moi je l'ai moi je c'est un
exemple que je donne souvent parce que
je l'ai vécu personnellement de
récupérer dans une station fruitière et
des stations frutières, il y en a des
milliers en France, euh de récupérer une
tonne et demi de fruits par semaine,
mais des fruits parfaits pour la conso
mur et tout. Mais en fait les gens faut
qu'ils comprennent que ils veulent tous,
ils disent "Oui, on veut ceci, on veut
cela, mais ils veulent des fruits ou des
ils veulent des carottes bien droites,
ils veulent des kiwiis ou des pommes qui
font
les carottes bien droites, c'est pour
faire autre chose.
Oui. Non mais il faut comprendre ça,
c'est que du coup les carottes enfin
soit elles sont décé si tu veux vraiment
en en fruits.
Euh moi je récupérais des pommes, des
prunes, des kiwi. Quand tu vois ce que
coûtent les kiwi, je récupérais jusqu'à
une tonne et demi de kiwi bio
et français. français, parfaitement mû.
En même temps, on est notre département,
on est le premier producteur de kiwi
maintenant. Mais euh parfaitement mû
mais juste trop gros ou trop petit pour
les calibreuses. Parce que pour que
quand tu vas dans ton supermarché et que
tu achètes ton pack de sikwi, il faut
qu'il soit standardisé pour que tu
fasses le même poids et que tout c'est
que de la c'est que du comment dire de
la commercialisation du j'ai plus les
mots mais on se comprend. Euh voilà.
Donc ça c'est la faute du consommateur
aussi. Faut que le consommateur il
apprenne que un légume qui est moins
beau, il est pas moins bon. Mais c'était
pas le claircit acheter des fruits et
légumes moches ?
Oui, mais alors ces gens-là, c'est
toujours pareil si tu veux, même si
l'initiative est louable. À quel point à
quel point est-ce que c'est un coup de
com pour verdir ton image ? À quel point
est-ce que c'est une démarche sincère ?
Je sais pas. Parce que ceux qui achètent
justement euh par million de tonnes de
la CAM standardisée, c'est eux. Donc ils
ont bondau derrière d'aller expliquer
ça.
On a reçu on a reçu monsieur Chelcher du
système U. Hm, faut pas dire Nutella
mais tu fais beaucoup la pub de système
quand même.
Non parce qu'on on l'a reçu, on avait
invité Leclerc mais Lecler il est pas
venu. Il a une piscine. En même temps,
Lecler en face de toi, tu vas avoir des
problèmes après.
Pourquoi donc ? Mais parce qu'il pèse
énormément. Donc si tu le si tu le
maltraites comme tu sais faire,
écoute, monsieur monsieur Chelcher,
c'était juste avant que ça cogne avec
les agriculteurs. Peut-être que son
passage chez nous, ça a épargné quel
le système, c'est possible. Ça a épargné
beaucoup de ses supermarchés parce que
il a crevé l'absè, il a proposé des
trucs. Bon sinon, on te propose de le
faire de de te le présenter.
Tu payes ton apéro ?
Bien sûr.
OK.
Je suis pour discuter avec tout le monde
hein. Donc
question internet. Pourrait-il parler du
phénomène des calibres ? Bah tu viens
d'en parler du phénomène des calibrages
de produits et nous dire où finissent
les produits non calibrés ? Ben il y en
a, moi je vais vous dire la la station
fruitière qui est très importante où
j'allais, jette 5 à 7 tonnes de fruits
par semaine, juste celle-là et de fruits
très bons et il paye pour que ce soit
détruit. Mais parce qu'en plus, il y a
les idées qui peuvent paraître bien sur
le moment de dire euh oui mais on va le
récupérer pour des associations ou quoi.
Mais après, tu vas avoir des gens, mais
ça je l'ai vécu en fait dans le monde
agricole, des gens qui vont venir se
plaindre. Oui mais en fait on nous donne
le déclassé. Oui, mais non, mais on vit
des trucs qui sont complètement fous. Je
je te donne juste un exemple. J'ai un
ami paysan boulanger qui marche très
bien qui tous ces invendus tous les
jours, il les amener au resto du cœur en
se tapant 20 bornes aller 20 bornes de
retour gratuitement. C'est c'est joli,
tu vois. Pain exceptionnel. et il fait
plein de plein différents. Et ben au
bout de 3 ou 4 ans qu'il faisait ça, il
a eu une remontrance de la directrice de
des resto du cœur de chez nous parce que
c'était pas régulier sur les pains.
C'estàd qu' a des fois ça être du pain
au noix, des fois il y avait pas assez
de baguettes, il y avait pas Elle lui a
dit ça, il a dit "Oui, il y a pas de
problème." Il est rentré chez Ah oui,
sûr à 100 %. Il est c'est un très bon
ami. Euh c'est tous ces invendus de pain
aujourd'hui vont à mes cochons. Donc tu
vois je je te le je connais tout ça.
Ah oui, ils ont beaucoup de chance parce
que bref je pas digresser là-dedans.
Mais euh
lui le jour où elle lui a dit ça, il a
même pas fait d'histoire. Il a dit "Oui,
d'accord. Il est rentré chez lui, il est
plus jamais revenu." Voilà, c'est des
réalités aussi.
Question internet. Quel exemple précis
d'un pays qui a perdu une part
importante de sa souveraineté
alimentaire vous marque particulièrement
? Quelle leçon en tirez-vous pour la
situation française ?
Alors, si je suis honnête, j'ai pas
d'exemple particuliers qui me choque
dans le sens qu'en fait c'est viable
pour
tous les quasi enfin tous non mais
quasiment tous les pays d'Afrique en
fait qu'on tient d'une manière ou d'une
autre. Et un exemple qui peut me
choquer, ouais, c'est l'Irak et les
accords avec les Américains. Pétrole
contre nourriture. Voilà, vous voulez un
exemple terrible, vous en avez un.
Question internet. Connaît-il le système
agricultural
des Pays-Bas ? Si oui, qu'en pense-il ?
Je prononce comme c'était écrit là.
Euh, je le connais un petit peu. Bon,
c'est un peu Matrix, hein, c'est
vraiment quand même assez industriel
mais c'est les Pays-Bas. Donc, il faut
quand même arriver si tu veux, tu fais
avec ce que tu as. Nous, on a une un des
meilleurs terroirs, voire même le
meilleur terroir, n'ayons pas peur des
mots, du monde. Euh, on arrive à avoir
énormément de productions différentes.
C'est pas le cas des Hollandais, ils
mangent des tomates de merde parce
qu'elles sont sous serr, elles ont un
goût de dire les endives, mais au moins,
ils essayent de produire hollandais et
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent avec le
climat qu'ils ont, les terres qu'ils
ont. Voilà, chacun fait ce qu'il peut
avec ses moyens. C'est
le réchauffement climatique. Est-ce que
tu vois de de des agriculteurs
décaler leur culture ou faire deux types
de culture ?
Ah mais on voit bien sûr. Oui oui bien
sûr. Bah surtout nous en Occitanie si tu
veux parce qu'on est vraiment les plus
impactés. Euh mais même en fait, tu vois
des vignes qui brûlent mais qui brûlent
pas de pas avec le feu qui brûlent parce
que tu montes presque je il y a quelques
années c'est arrivé un copain à moi, je
sais plus te dire 3 ans 4 ans euh où
c'est monté quasiment à 50°gr les vines
sont mortes. Euh
c'est on le vit très bien, enfin on le
vit très bien, non, on le pas on le vit
très bien, on le on le voit très bien
plutôt, pardon. Et ça nous impacte
beaucoup et donc il faut essayer
d'évoluer. Mais c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il y a une vraie urgence
sur la question de la gestion de l'eau
et du fait de pouvoir faire des retenus
collinaires et autres parce que sinon il
y a plus d'agriculture. C'est il faut
que les gens voient ce qui se passe en
fait. C'est voilà, je
il faut y travailler.
C'est ça. Faut venir le voir.
Ou ou il faut permettre au citadin
d'avoir le don d'ubiquité entre
les producteurs
et eux.
Oui,
en direct.
Mais après, je je voudrais dire aussi
une chose, c'est que les gens parlent du
prix de la bouffe, mais il y a aussi une
autre chose et je me mets dans l'eau,
hein, j'ai un smartphone comme tout le
monde, on achète des conneries tous
autant qu'on est.
Mais nos grands-parents ou nos arrières
grands-parents plutôt, 50 % de leur
budget, c'était la bouffe.
Nous aujourd'hui, on réduit ça au
maximum pour avoir un écran plat, un
smartphone, un
et en fait, il y a un sacré paquet de
merde qui nous rende esclave dont on a
peut-être pas si besoin. Alors, je suis
aussi esclave que tout le monde. Je
donne pas de leçon. Je dis juste que il
y a aussi ça. Tu peux pas dire que c'est
aussi qu'une histoire de portefeuille
parce qu'il y a aussi enfin qu'une
histoire de de revenu parce qu'il y a
aussi comment tu dépenses ton argent et
le premier acte politique qu'on fait
tous dans notre vie c'est dépenser notre
argent.
C'est quoi ton plat signature ?
mon plat signature
euh je dirais confit de canard
achi parmentier confit de canard
et avec du rockfort.
Euh on va parler un peu de ce que tu
fais. Euh ton petit cochon là euh tu le
nourris un peu avec du gland naturel.
Alors
parce que rien qu' a la couleur euh
Ah oui ah oui oui. Ça ça a pas la même
couleur que celui du supermarché. Ben
alors oui, parce qu'ils sont dans des
forêts chaînes châigniers. Donc ben là
en fait dans la période actuelle là, ils
se sont bien gavés de de châteignes et
de gland. C'est des périodes où il y a
presque plus besoin de les nourrir.
Après ils ont des des invendus de de de
pain et je leur fais une farine à base
d'orge, de féverol et de tritical. J'ai
mon moulin en fait et je leur fais la
farine tous les jours. Et donc après ben
on a la particularité, tu vois ce qui a
fait que j'ai choisi cette race.
Moi en fait, j'ai je voulais être paysan
si tu veux. Ça c'était l'évidence depuis
toujours. Et et en fait, j'ai cherché
une race particulièrement rustique,
jolie, tu vois, parce qu'ils sont assez
fun les les cochons. J'ai des cochons
laineux, tu vois, donc à poil long,
frisé. Et et on a un gras qui est
extrêmement bon pour la santé, un peu
comme une graisse de canard si tu veux.
Ouais. Sans sans abuser.
Non, non, mais c'est c'est un
il est meilleur que le gras, c'està-dire
il est pas saturé, il est très saturé.
Il est très il est riche en acide gras
insaturé et en comment on appelle ça ?
En oméga3 et il y a un autre truc que
j'ai sur le bout de la langue, je sais
plus. Bref,
c'est expliqué sur mon site pour ceux
que ça intéresse mais et donc tu as une
non tu as un gras qui est bien meilleur
que le beurre par exemple cuisiner au
sein doux de de cochons comme les miens,
c'est meilleur que le beurre pour la
santé tous les jours. Mais
je vais pas faire mes crêpes avec du
sein doux.
Pourquoi pas ?
Non.
Euh je t'assure que tu serais surpris.
Question internet. Quelle idée fausse,
très répandue-vous constaté sur ce que
coûte réellement ou rapporte
l'agriculture française par rapport au
discours officiel sur les aides et les
subventions ? Qu'est-ce qui cloche dans
la coopérative pour que autant de
paysans soient aussi mal financièrement
et se sentent aussi mal ? du temps de
mon grand-père paysan dans le Morvent,
il y avait une entraide et une
mutualisation qui ne laissait personne
dans la misère.
Alors oui, mais ça justement ce dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure, c'est-à-dire
le fait que on pousse les paysans
à vendre à la grande distribution et à
produire plus en fait a fait qu'on les a
mis en concurrence. Donc il a fallu
grossir. Donc ben on a tué énormément de
petites fermes et puis après en fait ben
c'est le jeu si tu veux petit poisson
devient gros en fait jusqu'au requin
quoi, tu vois. Et donc ben tu en as qui
ont réussi à bouffer tous les voisins.
Tu en as qui se battent comme des
chifonniers dès qu'il y a un hectare de
terre qui tombe alors qu'ils en ont déjà
largement assez. Euh
ça ça a créé déjà un vrai problème
là-dessus. Après les paysans, en fait,
il faut vous imaginer que euh des gens
les traitent limitent de fonctionnaires
euh parce que ils touchent de la PAC
dont ils ont pas voulu. Ils n'ont pas
voulu la PAC. Il y a aucun paysan qui a
voulu la réforme, voir comment Paris a
été bloqué à l'époque quand même. Euh
la Pâque en fait, c'est vraiment euh
comment dire ? C'est vraiment le truc
pour éviter les suicides, on va dire. En
fait, c'est que pour pas que tu coules
complètement, on te donne la pâque pour
qu'à la fin du mois, il te reste 900
balles, quoi. C'est voilà, c'est l'obol
qu'on te donne. Donc les gens, il faut
qu'ils comprennent que ceux qui les
nourrissent ont du mal à se nourrir.
Mais c'est vraiment une réalité en fait.
Euh,
comment dire ? Et puis après, il y a ce
truc aussi d'être traité en permanence
de polluer. Bien sûr qu'il y a des abus,
bien sûr qu'il y a des énormes bourrins.
De la même manière que j'ai défendu la
chasse, mais bien sûr qu'il y a des
chasseurs qui sont très panés. C'est
évident. Faut pas mais euh faut pas en
faire des généralités puis faut surtout
comprendre que les mecs leur terre c'est
c'est souvent quelque chose qui a été
commencé à travailler par leur père,
leur grand-père et cetera et ils en
prennent soin en fait. Ils se défoncent
pour ça, pour qu'on ait des beaux
paysages, pour qu'ils aient des belles
récoltes, pour que il y a un vrai amour,
un vrai lien à la terre en fait et de se
faire traiter de tout par des gens qui
n'ont aucune idée de ce dont il parle
quand en plus euh tu remplis pas euh ta
ta gamelle, c'est très très très
compliqué. Et ça aussi ça joue beaucoup
sur le mal-être le mal-être paysan et
c'est sur ça qu'il peut y avoir des
tensions avec les écolos même si je te
rejoins sur le fait que les écolos ne
font pas que des trucs inutiles bien
entendu. B
je te prends un exemple. Notredame des
landes. Tu as été baladé là-bas ?
Non.
Alors nous c'est bizarre on a été invité
là-bas euh faire un tournage à notre des
Landes et il s'avère que moi mon bonnet
il est rouge
parce que question cou plongé. Bon,
Saint-James rouge mais rouge rouge. Et
quand on a mis notre bonnet parce qu'il
faisait froid, on a vu un hélicoptère
débarqué. Les gars, ils ont cru que les
bonnets rouges débarquaient à Notredame
des Landes. Oui. Ou
et pas les écolos, Notre Dame des
Landes, c'était le paysage de bocage
de monde enfance avec le triton de monde
enfance, la salamandre de monde enfance.
Alors même si c'était des babes qui
faisaient des des de la pâte à sel et
que il y avait aussi
différentes communauté sur Notre Dame
des Landes avec bon les clodo, les pas
et les clodo, les anards, les pas et les
anards et ainsi de suite. Bon tout ce
petit monde avait quand même protégé le
coin. Donc je vais dans ton sens qu'ils
font quand même des choses.
Ah mais je te dis pas l'inverse. Alors,
Notre Dame des Landes, c'est pas un
sujet que j'ai particulièrement étudié,
donc je vais pas spécialement prononcer,
mais non, non, mais bien sûr que
défendre, enfin que protéger
l'environnement, c'est important, mais
il faut avant de vouloir protéger
l'environnement, il faut le connaître en
fait. Ça le problème, c'est les gens qui
voient un reportage et ils s'imaginent
qu'ils connaissent les animaux en fait.
Ils s'imaginent qu'ils connaissent la
nature, qui connaissent les sols, qui
connaissent et c'est terrible parce que
c'est énormément de connaissances. C'est
passionnant d'avoir la biovégétale, la
bioanimale. Bref,
comment tu fais pour abattre ton cheptel
pour faire tes tes jambons, tes
saucissons, ta poitrine fumée ?
Tu es obligé d'amener à l'abattoire.
D'accord. Et tu les amènes comment ? Tu
leur mets un peu
dans une bétaillère ? Non, pas de
musique mais Non, je les ben je les je
les piège entre guillemets. C'està-dire
que je rentre ma bétaillère là où je
l'ai nourris. Je mets à manger dans la
bétaillère, je laisse monter qui je
veux, je referme la bétaillère et puis
on s'en va et voilà. Mais je les amis,
tu les tu les entraînes un peu avant
pour pas qu'ils soient stré stressés ou
pas ? Ah non, ça les stresserait
justement.
Non, mais si tu les habitu à prendre le
camion
et oui, mais non parce qu'à chaque fois
que tu vas les mettre dans le camion, tu
vas les stresser. Moi justement, le but
c'est que c'est de les charger euh et de
les amener à l'abattoir le plus tard
possible pour qu'ils attendent le moins
longtemps possible à l'abattoir avant
d'être tués. Et et après bon ben il y a
ceux que je consomme moi et là je les
tue à la ferme en fait. Là c'est simple,
je leur mets une balle dans la tête
pendant qu'il mange et après je les
suspends et voilà. Mais donc là il voit
pas non mais c'est qu'il voit pas la
mort venir. C'est ça que je veux dire.
La viande est complètement différente.
Oui oui. Non mais bien sûr mais je vais
te dire quand tu élèves très lentement
et je suis pas le meilleur ou le seul en
France, il y a d'autres mecs qui
travaill très très bien avec des animaux
qui se élèvent longtemps et tout. Je
veux dire pas que je me mets pas je dis
pas ça genre c'est moi
surveill comment ton bétail où tes têtes
sont abatttues pour pas qu'il se
prennent des coups de later. Tu peux
pas.
Comment ça se fait que tu peux tu
puisses pas ?
Ben parce que tu amènes tes animaux et
après tu t'en vas. C'est c'est une
entreprise, c'est
Et tu les surveilles pas quand tu
reviens les tu reviens chercher les
carcasses en frigo.
Ah oui oui oui. Ah oui ça marche comme
ça. Ils sont tués la nuit de toute
façon. C'est
Et si tu voulais surveiller le processus
? Ben en fait, je vais te dire si les
animaux étaient particulièrement
maltraités, je vu que je travaille les
carcasses derrière, je le verrai tout de
suite en fait parce que Ah si, je
t'assure parce qu'en fait tu fais des
hématomes. Si tu leur mets des des coups
dans les cuisses ou quoi, euh moi je
peux pas faire un jambon derrière parce
qu'il y a un hématum. Euh si euh si
s'ils sont taillés, s'il sont le vois de
suite. Mais par contre, j'ai déjà vécu
ça dans il y a des années en arrière
quand j'étais stagiaire chez un gars qui
faisait du cochon les nœuds justement.
Et donc quand tu les lèves pendant 2 ans
bien, tu vois, tu verrais mes animaux
enfin ils sont à la coule de chez à la
coule.
Et en fait un cochon, si ça stresse
extrêmement la viande, elle devient
mousseuse. Et là, en fait, tu peux jeter
alors pas toute la carcasse mais tout le
morceau mousseux, tu le sors, tu le
jettes. Et ben quand tu te casses le à
élever un cochon pendant 2 ans et que tu
arrives et que tu jettes toute une
partie de la carcasse parce que pendant
les heures à l'abattoir, il a stressé
terrible.
Euh, c'est compliqué. Moi après, je vais
te dire, on est obligé légalement, on n'
pas le droit, il y a que en volaille, on
n' pas le droit nous de d'abattre à la
ferme. Mais si on pouvait abattre à la
ferme, au moins une solution que
j'aimerais développer qui n'est pas
faisable pour tout le monde, mais qui
est faisable pour les petits élevages,
c'est les abattoirs itinérants comme ça
commence à exister en Suisse, en en
Scandinavie et il commence à y avoir des
projets en France. Ça, j'aimerais
beaucoup, tu vois. Ça, je trouve ça très
bien. Mais non, après si tu veux, on
peut pas tout contrôler malheureusement.
Moi ce moment-là, je peux pas le
contrôler. On a vu une vidéo sur ta
chaîne YouTube où il y avait des
louftiers qui euh mettaient des coups de
fusil euh pour abattre ton cheptel entre
guillemets malade. Pas malade ou
euh pourquoi ils ont pas pris euh un
pistolet euh euh une p un pneumatique
parce qu'il faut les approcher.
Ah ouais
non non, il faut les approcher. Et bon,
c'est vrai que ça a été des images très
dures mais
c'est horrible.
Oui, à vivre c'est particulier. Mais je
leur en veux pas. Moi je la colère
terrible que j'ai, c'est un ver eux, ils
ont, excuse mon expression, mais ils ont
récupéré le bâton merdeux et ils ont
fait face et ils se sont pas dégonflés.
Bon, au moment du tir, ça a été un peu
n'importe quoi. Il y a eu des loupés, ça
a été un carnage. Bon, c'est comme ça.
Mais mais j'ai vraiment aucune ranqueur
envers eux. Au contraire, franchement,
c'est c'est des braves gars.
Franchement, ceux à qui j'en veux, c'est
la préfecture qui a géré ça n'importe
comment. Pour te donner un exemple, le
mien, ça c'est visible en vidéo. On m'a
battu deux fois mon cheptel en un an,
cas un monde, tout ce qu'on veut. Bon
bref euh la première année, j'ai une
dizaine de véos, deux barrages de flic
avant d'arriver chez moi. Un premier où
tu dois mettre une combinaison complète
et des surchaussures. Le deuxième, tu
mets une deuxième combinaison complète
et une deuxième paire de surchaussures.
Euh une dizaine de véau pour me tanasier
les animaux. Sauf qu'ils avaient géré
comme des chèvres. Donc bref, les
carissages pouvaient pas descendre. Il y
a eu des jus quand même partout. Enfin
bon, bref. Mais ils m'ont fait un truc
où c'était euh tu vois ça, tu avais
l'impression que c'était un site radio
radioactif, tu vois.
Peut-être que le
et on l'a filmé tout ça tout.
Peut-être que le virus Peut-être que le
virus était très dangereux.
C'est le même he ou
virus qui ne va pas à l'homme et
qui va au chien qui va ailleurs
qui va au chien. Bon, mes chiens sont
toujours vivants.
Euh
c'est à toi le berger allemand.
Ah ben elle elle est décédée mais de de
vieillesse très récemment. Mais oui, le
berger allemand les patou tout ça c'est
à moi. Même une alabée. Tu parlais du
kangal. Mais la labé c'est un peu comme
un kangal en plus gros. Oui,
c'est le Kangal, c'est le chien turc là.
Ouais. Laabé, c'est russe
le
à la baie
les mâles montent à 110 kg. C'est
bon je te fait changer du sujet c fait
exprès. Tu en penses quoi de Sainte
Soline et des méga bassines ? Comment ?
Autre question, je t'en envoie deux à la
fin parce que on va là c'est l'heure de
l'apéro.
Euh comment nous petits français
pouvons-vous soutenir votre combat ?
Alors, soutenir notre combat, première
chose, facile.
Moi, comme je l'ai dit, euh si le monde
agricole décide, parce que moi je suis
personne, si le monde agricole décide de
lancer un blocage national, moi je ferai
une vidéo qui me coûtera ce qu'elle me
coûtera, mais
j'expliquerai aux gens comment être
coquin. Voilà, ça je l'expliquerai le
moment venu parce que déjà, il faut que
je trouve comment le tourner pour me
protéger un petit peu légalement et puis
sinon de toute façon, ben c'est pas
grave. Mais euh ça c'est la première
chose. Donc voilà pour le combat
vraiment. Ben on verra quand on sera au
combat. Mais on a beaucoup parlé de
Macron. Macron il a monté une énorme
armée pour se protéger de son peuple.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a quand même des gros
moyens mis sur les les gendarmes mobiles
et les CRS. Mais à l'inverse, la police
est à poil, étant sous-effectif et
sous-équipé. Et euh du coup, la police,
voilà, ne pourra pas faire grand-chose
si on fait pas des manifes contre eux et
si on fait des petits actes coquins qui
marchent à 100 %. Voilà, mais je j'en
parlerai le moment venu. Euh
et j'ouvre une parenthèse. Euh autant tu
dis qu'il faut pas faire de généralité
chez les chasseurs, chez les machins,
mais il faut pas faire de généralité sur
les flics.
Alors, je l'ai dit tout à l'heure hein,
j'ai toujours défendu même les flics.
Quoi que ça me s évitez de vous trop
vous castagner. Euh voilà.
Non, mais si ça chauffe en fait, il moi
je pense vraiment que si ça chauffe en
particulier avec les paysans, je pense
qu'il y aura des boucliers posés,
sincèrement. Et en tout cas, je prie
pour que ça arrive parce que un flic qui
se bat avec un paysan enfin bon euh
question internet.
Non mais il y a
mégaabassine Soline.
Les méga bassines l'idée me fait pas
rêver mais elle me fait pas rêver
surtout pourquoi ? Parce que en fait
c'est des projets qui sont souvent menés
par des gens qui sont entre guillemets
près du feu, c'est-à-dire qui siègent où
il faut et cetera. et on va favoriser
des gens du syndicat majoritaire ou des
ou des énormes exploitants. Moi en fait,
je veux bien des mégabassines à partir
du moment où l'eau est répartie
équitablement entre tous les paysans,
mais je serai beaucoup plus pour des
solutions euh de retenu individuel
de taille limitée, hein, c'est pas un
problème, mais de retenu individuel,
voilà, et où les tous les paysans soient
logés à la même enseigne. Moi, pour moi,
c'est avant tout cette question de
justice. Après, les mégabassines, si on
fait des choses intelligentes autour, ça
peut devenir des super points de
biodiversité. Ça va devenir des gros
lacs en fait, tout simplement parce que
les paysans quand ils pompent l'eau, ils
n'enlèvent pas non plus complètement
tout. Donc, les animaux pourront
toujours boire et tu peux créer une fun,
une flore qui avait pas à cet
endroit-là. Donc
ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il y avait de
problématique, c'était les histoires de
ça pompe dans les nappes fréatiques.
Si c'est des bassins Si c'est des
bassins qui récupèrent les autres de
pluie pour irriguer euh la saison sèche,
je vois pas en quoi. Et alors après, on
va me dire "Mais en plus c'est pas des
eaux, c'est pas les eaux qui sont
absorbées." Enfin, même s'il y en a une
partie peut-être, mais en fait, c'est
des eaux de ruissellement. Donc le
ruissellement, bien sûr qu'il y en a une
partie qui est mais l'eau va quand même
rueler. C'est pas parce que tu as mis un
lac que la pluie va plus tu vois. Enfin,
c'est aberrant. Enfin à mon de mon
niveau, je suis pas ingénieur après.
Alors là, je vais lire un commentaire
qui est contre moi, mais je vais
l'expliquer. Je vais je vais Sky, avec
tout mon respect pour votre travail,
s'il vous plaît, pourriez-vous arrêter
d' d'infantiliser votre invité ne lui
disant ce qu'il faut dire ou ne pas dire
? Un grand merci. Alors ma petite Sarah,
je t'explique, on est déjà shadow bané
parce que à force de se prendre
frontalement des ambassadeurs et des
fumistes de prospectivistes qui raconte
n'importe quoi à longueur de journée
sans aucune expérience de terrain, on
est obligé de de mettre un peu de
temporisation surtout sur des invités
qui ont une expérience de terrain pour
un éviter de se faire sauter la chaîne,
un apporter la contradiction, de faire
l'avocat du diable et donc c'est
nécessaire et je suis désolé Sarah mais
je n'infantilise pas
mon invité et mon invité il fait 2 m10
et 145 kg et t'inquiète pas que si je
l'infantilis c'est trop si je l'infant
trop
mais c'est en vrai c'est bien c'est bien
de déstabiliser tu sais par rapport à la
à la sincérité du truc tu vois de pas
savoir de quoi on va parler de je le dis
pas tu vois j'ai rien à gagner à te
défendre mais factuellement moi
j'apprécie beaucoup que tu m'es invité
et et au contraire le fait d'amener de
la contradiction et de déstabiliser je
trouve ça super en fait comme exercice
donc non moi en tout cas je le ra merci
de m'avoir défendu mais je le prends
bien. Au contraire ça, enfin moi j'aime
bien. Je sais pas comment ça en vidéo
mais moi j'aime bien.
Question internet. D'abord je soutiens
la paysrainerie. Ma question est-ce que
l'agriculture française ne s'est pas
autodétruite depuis des années et laisse
mourir les sols quand on voit les champs
de maïs à perte de vue en Finister, les
champs de betterve dans la marne et
cetera et cetera, les fermes
industrielles enfermant des animaux dans
des conditions invivables. Pourquoi ne
pas lutter contre ça ?
Ah mais je suis pas du tout pour le
modèle industriel, je l'ai jamais été.
Après euh il y a modèle, il y a ferme on
va dire qui produit beaucoup et euh
usine si tu veux. Il faut quand même
savoir raison garder parce qu'on est là
quand même pour nourrir le pays. Donc il
faut quand même, on peut pas faire juste
trois carottes à un moment donné, il
faut quand même produire un petit peu.
Euh
moi, en fait, il reste trop peu de
paysans pour qu'on se divise. Moi, je
veux qu'on sauve les petites fermes,
mais je suis pas là pour jeter la pierre
sur les grosses fermes. Après, comme
l'on a dit, il y a grosses fermes et
grosses fermes, il y a des trucs où il
pètent les plombs. Et après oui, ben
comme je l'ai dit, je défends la chasse,
je suis chasseur, j'ai déjà mis chasseur
mais il y a des énormes abrutis, il y a
des abus, il y a des trucs qui n'ont ni
que ni tête, il y a des trucs qui sont
inhumains. Je suis d'accord là-dessus.
Au niveau des paysans, on a aussi nos
abrutis. Enfin, c'est ou des gens parce
qu' aussi vous voyez des grosses fermes
mais bien souvent en fait, on est revenu
au Moyen-Âge sur ces fermes là.
C'est-à-dire quand je dis revenu au
Moyen-Âge, c'est que c'est plus des
paysans, c'est des métayés. C'est-à-dire
que les mecs ils possèdent rien. En
fait, c'est un groupe ou un très gros
qui possède x milliers d'hctares et en
fait tous les gens que vous voyez
dessus, c'est juste des des salariés
agricoles. Et donc eux, ils font ce
qu'on leur dit et l'autre derrière, il
s'entonne parce qu'en fait c'est pas
c'est pas sa terre qu'il aime et qui
cultive lui-même. C'est une propriété
qu'il utilise pour ramener du pognon
mais il y vit pas. C'est c'est plus un
paysan.
la technologie dans le milieu agricole,
les GPS d'ailleurs volés pour être
envoyé ailleurs dans les pays de l'Est
où
tout ce qui est gestion du bétail,
mouvement du bétail et tout toute la la
technologie et de l'intelligence
artificielle dans le bétail ou dans la
production, qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Tu es un peu sensibilisé, ça te touche
pas encore parce que toi tu es un goû.
Je suis sur un modèle qui est pas touché
par ça. Mais bah le progrès
technologique du moment qu'il impacte
pas les animaux, tu vois, le bien-être
animal et qu'il est pas toxique,
j'ai rien contre factuellement. Euh
après dans l'agricole, ils pourront
automatis ils peuvent automatiser
beaucoup de choses, mais ça fait quand
même partie des métiers où on pourra
jamais mettre que des robots.
Euh
non, que dire ? Moi c'est pas, tu vois,
moi avec tout ce que j'ai vécu
maintenant, j'ai un très gros système de
vidéos surveillance sur mon
exploitation. Euh bon, je Non, enfin, à
un moment donné, il faut vivre avec son
temps dans le sens que je suis pas un
immense fan de Lia, mais aujourd'hui
dire que tu es contre Lia, super, mais
en fait, c'est déjà perdu, hein.
C'est c'est comme ça en fait. Ça c'est
un truc, c'est le soleil se lève, le
soleil se couche, ça te plaît, ça te
plaît pas, c'est fini.
Question internet. Quel modèle agricole
est soutenable dans un contexte de
réchauffement mondial à + 3° ? Donc + 6
% à pardon, je je je reprends. Quel
modèle agricole est soutenable dans un
contexte de réchauffement mondial à + 3°
Celus, donc + 6° Celus à 10° Celus sur
les terres ? Quels sont les scénarios
d'adaptation qui semblent crédibles pour
votre invité pour les prochaines années
pour supporter les sécheresses et des
règlements climatiques ? Entre
parenthèses, mais j'ai j'ai lu l'entre
parenthèses, on va organiser ça. C'est
pour un autre invité.
Euh l'innovation et on en est capable.
Moi, j'ai des j'ai un très très bon
copain qui innove beaucoup et euh qui
passe par exemple sur des productions
maintenant en France d'avocat de de
d'agrumes, tu vois. Des agrumes en
Occitanie, c'était pas enfin
d'Occitanie, si tu vas vers Montpellier
au Perpignan oui, mais chez nous vers
Agin, Monteoban, Toulouse, par là, des
agrumes, il y en avait pas. Euh en fait,
il va falloir faire évoluer nos Bien sûr
qu'il va falloir essayer de stocker de
l'eau, mais s'il y a plus d'eau, il faut
quand même trouver des cultures et des
productions qui en consomment moins.
Donc ben bien entendu, si on change de
climat, il faut s'adapter à des
productions qui sont en adéquation avec
ce climat. Il va pas falloir s'obstiner
à produire du maïs là où il y a pas
d'eau, par exemple. C'est c'est évident.
Faire des grosses bassines pour produire
du maïs là où il y a pas d'eau, à mon
sens, c'est une connerie. Est-ce que tu
connais des agriculteurs qui vont se
former par exemple au Maroc, en Algérie,
en Libye ? Non, pas en Libye, en
Tunisie, en Égypte ? Alors euh pour être
très honnête avec toi, alors en Algérie
euh
je sais pas trop ce qu' aurait à prendre
sans méchanceté mais c'est pas quand
même au Maroc il y a beaucoup
d'agricultur mais en fait au Maroc
l'agriculture elle est très au main des
Français ou des Israéliens des qui en
fait possèdent des exploitations
colossales. Moi un jour j'ai failli en
venir aux main avec un des des
actionnaires énormes de Grand Frais qui
nous expliquait hyper fier qui venait
d'investir dans 1000 hectares de tomates
au Maroc tu vois. Et en fait, c'est
beaucoup ça au Maroc. Donc non, il y en
a qui vont se former, qui vont se former
aux États-Unis, qui vont se former même
en Israël qui sont hyper techniques euh
ou dans différents pays. Oui. Benah de
toute façon maintenant, c'est quand même
souvent une volonté des pères de famille
quand leurs fils veulent reprendre la
ferme de les pousser à devenir ingénieur
agronome ou de les pousser à faire des
stages à l'étranger pour voir autre
chose et apprendre. Et si un jour bah
mes enfants veulent reprendre la ferme,
c'est exactement ce que je ferai pour le
coup. Donc euh Oui oui, il y a il y a
beaucoup de stages après les pays en
voilà.
Tu connais le les variétés anciennes qui
ne sont pas au catalogue des semences
ou le le
Cocopellie ?
Ouais. Cocopéli. Qu'est-ce que tu penses
de Cocopellie ?
C'est très bien.
Ouais.
Ils ont tout à fait raison
à 1000 %.
Ouais. Et nous on a fait pousser
pratiquement l'intégralité de leur
catalogue sur un coup de tête. Et ben
les tomates et tout tous les les
légumes,
c'est
moi les meilleures tomates que j'ai
mangé de ma vie, c'est ma voisine qui me
file les graines. C'est une vieille
variété qui existe pas ailleurs. D'ormes
tomates roses, mais un truc vraiment de
famille qui garde même.
Et tu connais le monsieur qui
sélectionne ses tomates sans eau depuis
des années là ?
Alors, j'ai eu vu quelques mecs qui font
comme ça du comment on appelle ça ? du
de la permaculture ou des systèmes, j'en
ai eu vu. Alors, je sais pas duquel tu
me parles ou mais j'en j'en suis
quelquesuns de permaculteur, je trouve
ça intéressant.
On lui on lui a commandé des graines.
C'est pas faisable. Il faut comprendre
que ça c'est quelque chose que les gens
peuvent faire chez eux pour leur
potager, mais il faut comprendre que si
tu veux faire une énorme production, ça
demande une quantité de travail énorme.
Il
il y a plein de chômeurs, ça tombe bien.
Ah mais ça c'est encore un autre sujet.
Ça c'est un autre sujet et c'est un des
gros problèmes de l'agriculture, c'est
que l'agriculture dépend de la main
d'œuvre étrangère.
Parce que les Français ne veulent plus
faire ce boulot-là. Ça c'est une
réalité. Euh pour aller ramasser des
fruits ou quoi, il y a que les Bulgares,
les Polonais, les Marocains qui viennent
par Charter entier pour bosser chez nous
à la belle saison parce que les gens ne
veulent pas. Alors c'est vrai que
là-dessus,
ils sont déclarés dans le meilleur des
cas.
Ouais. Alors, je t'assure quand même que
ça cogne très très très fort hein. Donc
non, mais il faut toujours et il y a eu
des scandales, il y a eu des histoires
presque d'esclavage. C'est une réalité
mais je te jure que c'est anecdotique
parce qu'en fait les mecs ont peur parce
que si les l'ursaf vient attraper euh
ce qui est normal,
j'ai pas dit l'inverse. Je dis que si
l'ursaf t'attrape, il y a mauvais temps.
Mais après là-dessus, moi voilà, moi je
suis pour de la solidarité pour un
système social, mais c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être bien de faire en sorte
que les gens travaillent.
Allez, dernière question et après on
passe à nos deux dernières questions.
Que pensent-il que pense l'invité de
l'augmentation des épidémies sanitaires
dans les élevage que ce soit la grille
avière, la machin de la
la dermatose nodulaire pour Oui. Oui.
Ben, j'en pense que ça va bien avec
l'agenda de destruction de l'agriculture
et de briser les gens en fait parce que
on parle de maladies qui sont pas
transmissibles à l'homme. qu'il faut me
raconter et
ça ruine un chapel entier, c'est
contagieux, ça peut ruiner les chept
côté
en beauovin c'est terrible parce qu'en
beauovin vraiment c'est des décennies la
génétique et donc on te détruit ce qu' a
commencé ton grand-père. En fait, les
animaux, tu es tu connaissais les
grands-parents, les machins, les ça
c'est moralement c'est impossible à
digérer en fait. Il y en a beaucoup qui
remettront pas de vache, hein. Mais
non, on est sur des maladies qui sont
même pas particulièrement euh meurtrier.
Enfin, ça dépend lesquels, mais la
dermatose nodulaire, par exemple, c'est
même pas particulièrement meurtrier pour
les vaches. C'est pas transmissible aux
hommes, la viande est consommable. Et
là, on vient enuthanasie tout le
cheptel, tout part, tout part à
l'écissage.
Et pourquoi ? Ben parce que c'est des
directives européennes une fois de plus
de mal ce qu'on appelle les maladies
classées. Je l'ai vécu deux fois en port
avec Ogki et les maladies classé c'est
plein de petites surprises sympas. Tu
peux pas faire de de contrexpertise
parce qu'une maladie classée, il y a que
les laboratoires d'état sermentés qui
sont une mini poignée qui peuvent faire
les test. Euh tu peux pas envoyer tes
prélèvements à l'étranger parce que
l'étranger, vu que la maladie est
classée, ne peuvent pas prendre le
risque de faire rentrer des souches dans
leur pays. Euh voilà, tu vois, c'est
quand ça t'arrive, surtout quand c'est
très suspect, c'est vraiment
particulier. Mais ça voilà, moi ce que
j'en pense, alors c'est peut-être un peu
complot ou ce qu'on veut, moi ce que
j'en pense c'est que c'est bien pratique
et que c'est de toute façon des
directives européennes et je connais pas
une directive européenne qui servent
l'agriculture. Donc voilà.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Trois livres à conseiller à ma enfin ma
non à ta communauté pardon.
À notre communauté. D'ailleurs, j'en
profite que tu réfléchis.
Soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous pour pouvoir résister. Euh euh ils
essayent désespérément de nous faire
terire et de nous neutraliser mais on va
pas se laisser faire et on a besoin de
vous. Tipi tipi tipi.
Alors je dirais l'être paysan de Jean
Gionau euh si on veut comprendre ce qui
va pas dans le monde agricole. Et en
fait si tu veux c'est je veux pas dire
une bêtise mais je crois que ça date des
années 30. Euh ça fait un peu comme avec
Or Corwell si tu veux. Il t'annonce un
peu ce qui va se passer. Euh l'être au
paysan de Jean Gionau. Après euh
après je dirais euh les animaux de la
ferme. Non, la ferme des animaux pardon.
Oui, c'est la ferme des animaux.
Dislectique en plus.
Non, juste un peu con. Mais euh donc
jamais tombé dans le misérabilisme de
l'impuissance.
Ça va, je tout va bien. Euh donc la
ferme des animaux et en trois, je dirais
l'art de la guerre de Sunzu.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui va rester
impérissable sur internet avant la
prochaine tempête solaire et la
prochaine guerre mondiale qui va nous
sur
accrochez-vous à vos accrochez-vous à
vos racines. Soyez fiers d'être ce que
vous êtes et dites à vos pères et vos
grands-pères qui râent toute la journée
sur le canapé de se sortir les doigts du
cul et de se battre pour vous parce que
si on en vient à des temps compliqués,
vous il vous faut étudier pour préparer
votre futur et c'est les autres qui
doivent aller au charbon.
Voilà.
Pierre Guillaume Mercadal. Merci. Merci
à toi.